hello everyone welcome to the October
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll this is yet again one of those
podcasts that is being recorded remotely
I'm on the road traveling so as usual
I'm going to hope that the various audio
quality issues don't get in the way I
think this is going to be pretty good
though I think I have a pretty good
temporary uh mobile podcasting setup
that should be fine so hope that's okay
the travel is an aspect is is one of the
manifestations or one of the causes I
suppose I should say that I have been
very busy recently even more busy than
by my usual standards which is why this
AMA is coming out on the second Monday
of the month I just did not have the
time to get it together the AMA last
week usually the AMA comes out at the
beginning of every month unless there's
some reason why some particular other
podcast should come out then hope that's
not too much of an inconvenience for
anyone uh there were a lot of questions
a lot of great questions so I was kind
of brutal cutting them down this time
apologies about that as always uh no big
news here but uh one fun thing to
mention is that part of the reason I was
busy is not only traveling myself but
hosting other people coming in and
recently at John's Hopkins we had a
visit from Scott Aronson well-known
theoretical computer scientist Quantum
Computing guy complexity guy and former
mindscape guest as well as as some of
you know a collaborator of mine on one
paper we've known each other for a long
time but we've only written one paper
together which was on the origin and
evolution of complexity in the universe
the rough idea being that in a closed
system entropy grows if you start with
low entropy in a closed system the
entropy will increase with time until
you equilibrate but complexity first
grows and then shrinks or it just
doesn't grow at all this is a good kind
of open question so the whole question
of the origins of complexity and its
relationship to statistical mechanics
fascinates me obviously there's been a
lot of work done on complex systems
features of complexity things like that
but they generally presume from the
start some kind of time directedness to
the environment or the Dynamics like
energy is being inserted or something
like that there's some resource that is
being used so looking specifically at
closed systems I think is a is a new
thing and kind of interesting so I
forget how much of the story you all
know but years ago Scott and I wrote
this paper uh with Lauren wette no
relationship to Jennifer wilette my wife
it was just an accident a coincidence
Lauren was at the time an undergraduate
MIT and what we did was we did some
numerical simulations of cream mixing
into coffee because cream and coffee
mixing into each other is an example of
how you can start with low entropy and
simplicity and evolve to to high entropy
and also Simplicity passing through a
complex phase but we realized not not we
I have to say we put the paper online
and we were told by uh some emailers
that in fact we had made a mistake in
fact one person in particular Brent Wess
pointed out that we had made a mistake
and he was completely correct about that
uh but it was actually good news because
we fixed the mistake and the result with
the mistake fixed is much more
interesting than the result we thought
we had originally basically some kinds
of Dynamics for the cream and coffee
mixing together do not lead to
complexity other kinds do and so now we
have a new question that we can really
try to get a hold on how do you divide
the set of dynamical laws governing the
mixing that will and will not lead to
complex structures evolving so we have
some vague ideas we have some new
numerical simulations and even though
it's more than 10 years later we're
we're not you know we're both busy
people we didn't have quite the uh oomph
to pull it off uh now Scott and I are
finally finishing the paper and Brett
will be another co-author on it and so
we have all the new simulations done we
just have to write some text uh which we
were doing while Scott was visiting he
also gave a talk uh and it's great so
that'll be coming out soon and hopefully
I think leading to other research
projects I mean we really in some sense
look at the simplest most naive
definition of complexity anyone who
knows anything about complex systems
research knows that the idea of
complexity is quite subtle and
complicated and you can go into details
about what you mean by complexity and
there's different aspects and we can
think about how all of them might arise
through the undirected disel loic
evolution of uh atoms bumping into each
other in a closed system so I'm thinking
about that uh as a future research
Direction and that's very exciting
anyway that's my little excuse for not
getting the AMA out earlier but it's all
for a good cause they come out
eventually anyway no one really loses
anything remember that the ask me
anything questions every month are being
asked by uh patreon supporters of
mindscape and you could easily be a
patreon supporter all you have to do is
go to patreon.com shanm Caroll and sign
up to kick in a dollar or however much
you want per podcast uh and that's it
then you can ask the questions and you
also get adree versions of the podcast
and also you get access to the little
reflection videos and audios that I do
after each podcast exclusively for
patreon supporters so we appreciate that
very much and with that let's
[Music]
go
we'll start with joy colbeck who says
could you give a good update on the
mindscape scholarship recipients which
courses they've chosen how they're
progressing and so forth it feels good
knowing we are all supporting the
thinkers of tomorrow with our donations
right this reminds me there's sort of a
good news bad news situation here the
good news is we have a scholarship fund
here at mindscape and you are welcome
and encouraged to contribute to it all
you have to do is go to bold.org
scholarships slm mindscape I think it's
SLS scholarships you can look it up if
you go to b.org and um search for
mindscape you will definitely find it
and the gimmick that we do is we try to
give scholarships to people who want to
go to college and study the big pictures
whether it is science or philosophy or
math or whatever something that is you
know very academic and ambitious and
especially the scholarship is oriented
towards people who are not already from
you know their parents or professors and
stuff like that right we want to get new
blood into the area that that's one of
the hopes and last year we were
incredibly successful we raised over
$220,000 and so we gave two scholarships
worth $10,000 each which is not enough
to cover an entire undergraduate
education typically but it that does
make it difference it does goes go a
certain way and it was Raymond Hassan
and leat mes that were winners I don't
know how to pronounce the 's last name
sorry about that mes mise um but we were
very very happy they both had
extraordinarily good applications and so
that was a heartwarming thing that we
did the bad news is I have been very bad
about keeping up with them so Joy your
question is going to uh nudge me to
catch up because you know we gave these
out I think that they were both still
high school students so hopefully
they're both in college now at
University and uh doing whatever they
want to do there's no
uh requirements once you get the
scholarship by the way if either one of
them wants to go to university and then
decide to study to be a veterinarian or
Wall Street Banker that is completely
fine we just want to encourage people
whose um Impressions at the moment or
that they want to do the kind of thing
that mindscape specializes in but then
once you get it you can do whatever you
want there's no reports no annual
updates or anything like that but I'll
try to chase down Raymond and leot and
ask uh how things are going I hope that
they're going very well so that was a
good question and uh yeah and again
please feel free to donate one thing
that I I can't figure out a way to do is
to how to thank the donors um there was
one donor who recently gave
$2500 which is amazing to me which is
wonderful you know again warms my heart
uh very very much appreciated by the
people who are ultimately going to
receive the scholarship but I have no
way to you know send them an email and
say thank you so here I go thank you
very much I don't know I'm not going to
say whose name it was I don't know if
they want their name said but I know who
you are and I very very much appreciate
it uh it's nice to think that we can do
a little bit of good here at mindscape
World
Headquarters then Alex T asks I've
enjoyed listening to mindscape for
several years in many of your AMA
answers you seem to hedge quite a bit
I've grown to appreciate your approach
to truth and knowledge and how the
Precision of language complicates
putting down objective fact my question
is are there any any subjects or
statements that you would consider
unequivocally true well it's interesting
I don't know I would have to be given an
example of the hedging to understand
better what it was that you had in mind
about my hedging I'm not saying that I
don't do it I'm sure you're right maybe
what you're referring to is simply the
fact that I'm always very reluctant to
put zero or one as my Credence in just
about any proposition you might want to
float out there I think this is just a
good basy in practice but if you're
practical question Alex is uh are there
any subjects or statements that you
would consider unequivocally true
well you know we could be brains in Vats
right we could be uh being taunted by an
evil demon all those skeptical scenarios
that philosophers love to come up with
are are possible in my mind so I I don't
like to consider things unequivocally
true on the other hand there are some
things that are sufficiently high
Credence that I'm not going to worry
about them I'm not going to bother to
put a lot of intellectual effort or time
into thinking about whether or not those
things are true they're true enough
they're they're sufficiently likely in
my mind to be true that I don't worry
about them I move on with my life and
try to build on them and this can have
even that has sort of different levels
of precision you know um general
relativity is very accurately describing
gravity in the solar system I consider
that at very very very high Credence for
example uh when I wake up tomorrow
gravity will still be attractive things
like that those are so high I can't even
imagine uh bothering you know uh worried
about you know worrying about
Alternatives but then there's like the
interesting gray area where I do think
there is more than a 1% chance that the
idea is wrong but as a researcher who
spends his life trying to think about
ideas and develop them and push them
forward I nevertheless have to pick and
choose what are the ideas I think are
worth considering so I'm actually more
open-minded on the podcast than I am in
my research career you know I will talk
to people who are not fans of the ever
interpretation for the for example I
will talk to Pan pists about
Consciousness and so forth but those are
ideas that I put you know essentially no
Credence on as a practical matter as a
researcher you know I think that you
know pan psychism has a chance or bowan
mechanics has a chance or whatever but
I'm not being open-minded about them
when I do my research in physics or
philosophy uh and this is but being a
weird situation that because I I think
that I do research in the foundations of
quantum mechanics but when you go to a
conference on the foundations of quantum
mechanics there's an enormous amount of
work being done by people who are
studying not ready in approaches and I
think that that's perfectly okay but I
am just not an expert on that stuff I'm
not especially interested in that stuff
I just want to figure out how to use the
everan approach to figure out how the
universe works and this is something you
know i' I've gained some clarity about
over time I remember back in the day
when I was a graduate student meeting
someone
who was a string theorist and he was
working on cosmological implications of
string theory and I mentioned something
I was working on that was not String
Theory based but cosmology was actually
close to what he was doing but it was
not String Theory based and he said yeah
I'm not especially interested in that if
it's not String Theory based and at the
time I thought that was outrageous you
know like what are you why are you so
closed-minded about this but now I
completely get it I think that that's
perfectly valid it would be a big
mistake if the community did that it's
very good that there are some people who
are studying different Alternatives but
as a single researcher you got to pick
your battles you can't just think about
every idea that's just not plausible and
you're going to be more effective if you
focus your attention somewhere so that's
not exactly uh the question that Alex
asked but reminded me of that question
so that's the answer you got Mark bue
says priority question does the remember
um people who are AMA supporters get to
ask these priority questions which means
once in their life they can label a
question by priority and then I will
answer it the answers might not be
satisfying in fact I suspect that they
are frequently not but I will absolutely
do my best to provide an answer to it
you only get to do it once and so if you
have a question that you absolutely want
answered try it out as a non- priority
question first and then if I don't
answer it uh just ask it as priority
I'll do my best so Mark asks does the
block universe theory imply that motion
is unreal or an illusion and sometimes
also implied that every moment is a kind
of Eternity not of duration but some
other kind which I couldn't understand
and that nothing happens in it if yes
how does the thing we observe every day
make sense and to even have an illusion
of some kind of motion seems to be
necessary what has it to do with
eternity uh no it the block universe
theory does not not imply that motion is
unreal or an illusion motion means that
you have something called position as a
function of time the block universe
theory just says that every moment of
time is real that doesn't mean you don't
have position as a function of time in
the block Universe at different times
things can be at different locations
that's what motion is the temptation to
think that the block universe theory
somehow implies that motion is an
illusion or unreal comes from drawing a
picture of the block universe theory and
then pretending that it exists all at
one moment of time but it doesn't all
exists at one moment of time it just
exists I know that's a subtle
distinction so I will say it again the
block universe theory or eternalism in
the philosophy of time does not say all
moments of time are simultaneously real
it just says they're all real by
definition
they are not simultaneously real they
are real at different moments of time
because they are different moments of
time our language as usual is kind of
shaky here it's not really up to the
task of describing these things well but
ill motion is fine that there's no
problem with that there's a closely
related question in quantum gravity or
even in some classical versions of
physics where you drop time as a
fundamental parameter and treat it as a
mergent even there I would say that
motion is real it's not elusory but the
steps to get there are trickier I will I
will admit that we're not going to do
that right
now Peter M Caruso says if we could look
at our universe from the outside what
would its shape be well we don't
know so crucially we can look at the
universe from the outside for one thing
now for another thing remember I presume
you're talking about the universe at one
moment of time right you're talking
about sort of a spatial slice
through our universe not like we were
just talking about the whole
four-dimensional block Universe picture
right uh that's a whole another question
what would it be look like to look at
our whole space time from the outside
because we can't do that we exist at
individual moments of time our our world
lines are the collection of all those
moments but at any one moment we exist
at just that moment so I presume you're
asking about you know the spatial slice
through the universe and in relativity
that's not even a uniquely defined
question right we can't even say here is
the right way to slice the universe the
SpaceTime of the universe into moments
of time once and for all uh it's there's
some Freedom there and that freedom
might not make a big difference if you
here on Earth SpaceTime is close to Flat
everything's moving slowly compared to
the speed of light but when you're
talking about the whole universe then it
begins to matter okay but those are some
technicalities um there's also the
well-known fact that if the universe is
thought of as perfectly homogeneous and
isotropic in space okay so homogeneous
means the geometry is the same at Point
from point to point and isotropic means
the geometry is the same in every
direction those are not exactly the same
statement although they sound similar
because you could have let's say a
magnetic field at every point in the
universe and that would have a direction
at every point so that would the
universe with a magnetic field that was
uniform throughout it would be
homogeneous same at every point but it
would not be isotropic because it would
have would have a preferred Direction
but if you have both if you have
homogeneity and isotropy which the
evidence is that we approximately do on
large scales in the observable universe
then you only have three choices for the
local kind of curvature that SpaceTime
can have namely SpaceTime can be flat
positively curved or negatively curved
that is to say like a three-dimensional
ukian geometry or a three-dimensional
spherical geometry or a
three-dimensional hyperbolic geometry
and in still all those cases the global
completion of the geometry could be
different um you can have a flat
geometry locally and that geometry could
go on forever you just just have you
know the infinitely big ukian three
dimensional space or you could be part
of a Taurus right you could be like The
Asteroids game where when you go out one
side you come back the other one so the
universe could be a three-dimensional
Taurus wrapping in on itself the same
thing holds true if it's positively
curved or negatively curved you can have
these uh weird topological ways the
universe could close in on itself the
Only Rule is that if the curvature is
positive everywhere then the universe
has to close in on itself there are
still different ways to do it there's
more than one Global geometry but
they're all finite in size if there's a
minimum value of positive curvature
everywhere whereas if the universe has
if space I should say has zero or
negative curvature then it could either
be finite or infinite we just don't know
but then there's another complication I
should say one last thing there which is
that the data say that empirically the
universe is close to flat but there are
error bars on that and close to Flat is
exactly when you don't know exactly what
the answer is right because close to
Flat includes flat almost flat but
actually positively curved and almost
plat but actually negatively curved both
of those are allowed by the data um so
we don't know is still the answer to
your question finally of course when it
comes to the universe we only see part
of it we don't see the whole thing so
sometimes cosmologists talk about these
models of the universe flat positively
curved negatively curved as if they are
correct or as if they are the only
option but that's flat out wrong they
only refer to the universe when it is
homogeneous and isotropic and it might
very well be approximately homogeneous
and isotropic within the observable bit
but wildly different outside and in
particular in ideas like Eternal
inflation the universe is wildly
different outside so then the global
geometry would just look like a chaotic
mess and there's really nothing more
that I can say than that so we truly
don't know is the only good sensible
answer I can give to that particular
question Carlos Nunes says on the topic
of misinformation presely referencing
the brandan Nan uh podcast we recently
did do you agree with the idea that
freedom of speech doesn't equal freedom
of reach what would you say to the
freedom of speech fundamentalists that
believe that any infringement of freedom
is negative even when it prevents the
spread of
misinformation well I kind of don't like
simplistic motto like this freedom of
speech doesn't equal freedom of reach I
mean of of course I'm sympathetic to the
general idea it's true freedom of speech
doesn't mean you can force people to
listen to you like that would be absurd
to think that it doesn't mean that
private corporations are necessarily
obligated to carry your words if they
don't want to there's nothing in either
the legality of the First Amendment here
in the United States or in moral or
political or ethical philosophy
that says that every company is
obligated to amplify your speech that is
just completely true and trivially true
um but of course it's complicated and I
you know I think it's okay to be
complicated this is a freedom of speech
as a topic is one where people really
seem to not want to use their brains too
much because it might hurt them this is
a topic where you have to think about
things carefully there are balancing
values that we have we want everybody to
be able to speak we want everybody to be
able to say their minds we do not want
to pass laws or regulations that prevent
people from talking but that doesn't
mean that they can talk in any venue
they want with any loudness they want
right so we have other values that we
have in our society
misinformation um just you know
misinformation can be as simple as
shouting fire in a crowded theater for
example or it could be more blatant lies
you know every country has its um
liebell laws and its defamation laws and
things like that these are restrictions
on speech you can say things but then
you'll be punished for them and and
that's okay that's perfectly 100% okay
and it's hard to draw the line exactly
so the very first step in thinking
sensibly about freedom of speech is to
admit that we have to sit down and think
about it hard that we can't just boil it
down to motto so uh that doesn't give us
a simple answer you know that philosophy
doesn't let us uh immediately go from
that to saying okay therefore the
following restrictions on misinformation
are allowed I think it's a very tricky
question I am much more in favor of
freedom of speech than the average
person I'm completely on board if some
University group wants to invite some
terrible terrible terrible person to
give a talk uh and I say that online and
some people say yes I completely agree
with you except for the really terrible
people and my response is no I actually
I mean even the really terrible people
uh if some individuals want to listen to
a really terrible person I think that
should be allowed others should not be
forced to listen to them I do not
believe that you should Heckle people
off the stage or anything like that you
can just not go you can just counter
program you can set up your own speech
that says things that that explain why
the person is wrong I think that's the
right way to do it again it's
complicated uh you don't want people
coming and inciting violence for example
and you know there's oh there are going
to be gray areas and I think again yet
again I'm going to keep saying it again
and again because people don't believe
me you have to think hard about the gray
areas and maybe you have to even admit
that they will remain a little gray they
will never be cleared up by some simple
motto that makes everything cut and
dried Blake braer says I'm an electrical
engineer by trade and I've often thought
it is a terrible historical mistake that
the charge of the electron was decided
to be negative instead of positive my
question is do you think
electromagnetism and electrical
engineering would be easier for people
to comprehend if we all agreed to swap
polarities on all things carrying
electrical charge such that anything
positive would be negative going forward
and vice versa or is there there's some
fundamental reason the charge of the
electron should be negative and not
positive that I'm simply not
understanding uh I don't think either
one of those is true Blake sorry about
that um there's no fundamental reason
the charge in the electron should be
negative it goes back to the days when
they were first studying electricity but
had no idea there were things called
electrons right they discovered
electricity long before they knew that
what electricity was was the motion of
light Elementary particles that we now
call electrons so they had to choose you
know what was positive what was negative
they made a choice 50/50 chance they got
it wrong you know they it it absolutely
would be more
convenient if the electrical charge were
defined by convention to be positive
rather than negative however it is not
so much more convenient that it's worth
switching there are t there are costs to
changing a convention that everyone
agrees on just ask any country that is
Switched from Imperial weights and
measures to metric right in the case of
going from Imperial to metric there are
clear benefits that are pretty big right
dividing by 10 is a lot easier than
doing some of the wacky things that uh
imperial units demand that we do so I
think that the case could be easily made
that metric is just better but the
positive sign versus the negative sign
in electromagnetism in electricity in
particular the charge of the electron is
a relatively minor thing you can handle
it so it would if to change it would
cause a whole bunch of headaches because
we have books we have papers that are
written with the existing sign
convention and if you started the idea
that going forward all books and papers
have a different sign convention they're
suddenly incompatible with each other
and a million other little tiny annoying
worries I guarantee you the headaches
that would come along with changing the
convention are noticeably bigger than
the benefit you would get from the
ultimate change change having been
accomplished Michael freed says I was
under the impression that when a lot of
matter occupies a very small space a
black hole will form when I hear about
the big bang it sounds like all the
matter in the universe was compressed
into a very small space I was under the
impression that under our current
understanding of the laws of physics
that much matter in such a small space
must create a black hole how was all the
matter energy in the universe able to
escape such a small space preventing a
black hole from forming good I like this
question cuz it's easy uh you are not
correct you are not under the right
impression it's not your fault cuz I'm
sure you've been told this but it is not
correct to say that when a lot of matter
occupies a very small space a black hole
will form as a necessary conclusion and
there's even a nice little bit of
thought that you can put into it that
explains why that's true namely general
relativity as a Theory of physics is
invariant under time reversal that is to
say any solution that we have to general
relativity has implies the existence of
another solution which is just the same
solution but running backward in time
okay you know this from regular old
Newtonian mechanics if there's a
pendulum rocking back and forth you can
rock it back and forth backwards in fact
it looks exactly the same if you uh
throw a baseball one way you could throw
it backwards along the same trajectory
it is also a good solution so if you
imagine
a perfectly legitimate solution to the
equations of general relativity of the
form I have a planet or a star and it
collapses to make a black hole okay then
you know that there's another solution
that says there is the time reverse of a
black hole and it spits out a planet or
a star now there is something called The
Arrow of time entropy increases with
time so even though strictly speaking at
the microscopic level such Solutions to
the equations must exist that doesn't
mean they actually happen in the real
world there are solutions where
scrambled eggs unscramble or cream and
coffee unmix from each other that
doesn't mean that they're realistically
going to happen but they are solutions
to the equations and therefore you know
the statement that if there's a certain
amount of matter in space there must be
a black hole in its future can't be
right because maybe there is a white
hole which is the opposite of a black
hole the time riverse of a black hole in
its past Carlo relli one of the very
first mindscape guests just came out
with a new book or maybe is coming out
soon uh called white holes if you want
to read more about white holes he thinks
they might actually exist I'm a little
more skeptical about that so the Big
Bang as a solution to the equations of
general relativity is very very very
much like a white hole it has a
singularity in the past rather than the
future and matter comes out of it rather
than falling into it so the whole
situation is 100% okay if you want to
less technical more handwavy uh give
yourself a warm and fuzzy feeling
explanation the universe was expanding
very rapidly after the big bang the
matter was all moving apart from
everything else it was moving apart so
fast that did not form a black hole if
you like that explanation better go nuts
with it but one way or the other nothing
whatsoever is being violated as far as
the laws of physics are
concerned Ryan Santos says I feel like
the popular speculations about
extraterrestrial life are too
constrained do you think there's any
special reason to presume that life
elsewhere is necessarily Planet bound
and subject to restraints like
ours no I mean I don't think there's any
uh necessary reason to presume that not
if you put the word necessarily in there
then the answer is going to be no you
know life can be lots of different
things uh I think it was
um oh my goodness Fred Hoy the
astrophysicist
who was a was a champion of the steady
state theory of the universe who wrote a
book about life in a giant molecular
cloud had nothing to do with living on a
planet whatsoever Robert forward of
course wrote a story about life on a
neutron star so I think you can be very
open-minded about the possibilities but
I I would say two things number one we
know life can exist on a planet we know
a lot about how it can can exist on
planets so given that the space of
possibilities is very very very big I
think it makes perfect scientific sense
to mostly focus on the regimes in which
we know a little bit about what might
happen that's perfectly legitimate
scientific practice I think and secondly
I do think that there are reasons to
think that planets serve as good
environments for Life forming you know
we don't know a lot about the origin of
Life Etc but it's easy for us to imagine
the planets have the right kind of
environment the right kinds of
conditions for life to form whereas in
other more extreme environments you
really have to stretch yourself a little
bit so even though it's not necessarily
true that life should be Planet bound
it's wouldn't be surprising to me if
most of all the life that we find
elsewhere turns out to
be Tim
gianos Janos ah Janos sorry Tim I'm just
not doing a good job with your name
today there's a famous paper by John
Wheeler where he makes some bold
statements and argues that they are
these bold statements are basically
irrefutable what is the stance of the
modern physics community on them the
world can't just be a machine ruled by
Continuum physical law there is no such
thing at the microscopic level as
SpaceTime and bits are the most
fundamental reality well I I think that
all these are quite refutable at least
if what you mean by that is we can
coherently sensibly imagine that they
are not true or true in any useful way
um you know John Wheeler was a brilliant
physicist and he made a lot of good
contributions he was also quite fond of
exaggerating and he was also quite fond
of poetic language so sometimes his
statements are not clear enough for us
to even really say whether they're right
or wrong so when you say things like the
world can't just be a machine ruled by
Continuum physical law I never knew the
world was a machine ruled by Continuum
physical law so for one thing what do
you mean by machine in particular do you
mean it's mechanistic do you mean it's
deterministic do you mean it is uh
non-teleological do you mean that it
obeys rules like I have no idea what
that word is supposed to mean in that
context maybe the relevant world word in
this sentence is Continuum you know
maybe he is being skeptical about the
real numbers as opposed to the integer
about smooth quantities rather than
discreet quantities I think in that case
it's absolutely unknown whether or not
the world could be completely Continuum
or whether or not it could be and is
discreet I think we should be
open-minded about that whether there is
such a thing at the microscopic level as
SpaceTime you know I don't think that
there is but there could be I mean come
on how do we know these things and bits
are the most fundamental reality how do
you know what the most fundamental
reality is how does John Wheeler know
that I don't I think that uh this one is
is the closest I would say to just being
wrong bits are the most fundamental
reality I think that bits are
descriptions of reality you know numbers
are not the most fundamental reality
numbers are ways that we use ideas that
we appeal to when we describe reality uh
there is a paper I wrote that is online
you can find it simply called reality
realism I think I mentioned it here
before
the idea being that physical reality is
real nothing else is quite as real as
physical reality things like energy and
information and Mathematics are all
different properties and descriptions of
the underlying physical reality uh that
might turn out to be a bad point of view
the point of view that I just advocated
right there I'm open-minded about that
but let's not get ahead of ourselves let
let's think of these as you know
provocative statements that make us
think not things that are basically
irrefutable George Hampton says what led
you to write these new books did the
pandemic have much to do with it yeah
the pandemic had a lot to do with it uh
I did videos on the biggest ideas in the
universe series you can find them on
YouTube something like 48 videos of me
sitting at my iPad and writing out
little pictures and little equations and
trying to explain physics and since I'd
done that much work along the way I
thought it would be uh relatively useful
and straightforward to turn them into
books famous last words of course it's
been an enormous amount of work I have
two of the books written one more to go
uh and the reason why it's hard is
because when you're writing a book there
there's two things the whole gimmick
here was that I was trying to be a
little bit more detailed than you
usually get a little more quantitative
there are equations stuff like that and
that's fine but it is a different kind
of mode to be writing in the purely
technical mode where you're writing for
students who are in a curriculum and
have had certain prerequisites and are
guaranteed to be uh invested and
incentivized to do the problem sets and
stuff like that that I can do that I've
done that's a very standard way of
writing physicists any any person in a
technical field knows how to do that and
the popular way of writing where you
don't have equations where you're trying
to make things as understandable as you
can without reference to all the
detailed quantitative um equations but
other you know statements about the
theory definitions and things like that
that I know how to do
too so it was too easy in writing the
new books to lapse into a purely
technical way of talking right uh well
you've seen this equation before now
let's put it to work and that's just
hard like I don't shy away from showing
the
equations but it has never been true
even for the most bright physics
graduate student that you just see an
equation and you instantly internalize
it even if you understand what all the
symbols mean the implications of it the
way you should think about it without
explicitly solving it all of that stuff
is an intuition that you build up over
time and practice and in the course of a
very short book you know in the new book
Quant and fields we go very deep into
Quantum field Theory you know like
quantum mechanics all by itself is I
forget either just three or four
chapters at the beginning it's pretty
quick and then we go right into field
Theory findan diagrams renormalization
symmetry breaking
confinement um effective field theories
the spin statistics theorem all this
stuff you know is covered in a
remarkably short period of time so the
real real real challenge was including
enough of the details that it was used
ful and didn't seem like cheating
without um going you know relying on the
obviously incorrect assumption that I
could just show people an equation
explain it and they would instantly get
it and we could move on you have to like
be able to relax catch your breath think
about it really think things through a
little bit so anyway that's not the
question you asked but um it is an extra
challenge that arose in writing these
books and I think that that's that was
part of the motivation because I wanted
to do something different you know these
books are purely
pedagogical I am not pushing any new
agenda or any new Theory or breaking any
new ground on our understanding of the
universe and usually when I write books
I am or at least I am trying to make an
argument for something that you are
welcome to disagree with whether that
argument is about the arrow of time or
the foundations of quantum mechanics or
the underlying ontology of philosophical
naturalism the books that I like to
write are ones that take a stance and
say something new so this book these
books this series of purely pedagogical
books is something different and I
wouldn't have done it if I couldn't do
something that I thought was different
you know do it in a different way so
even though the content is not new and
you know it's mostly decades or
centuries old the way that I'm trying to
do it is new and that made it
interesting for me Fran pla says in
episode number 41 with Steven strogatz
you mentioned that you were taking
melatonin when you were in different
time zones so does so to connected to
episode 251 with jet lag eating early
and daylight is good measures to adjust
our internal clocks my question is are
you still taking melatonin to combat jet
lag well I haven't taken it in a while
um I haven't been doing that much
international travel in a while so I
didn't really need to do it but I would
take it yeah I have no objections to
doing it
I I think that uh my experience with
melatonin's been very good I generally
will take it uh the first couple days if
I'm doing a long trip that I'm going
very far away and either to depending on
which direction I've gone in to fall
asleep at bedtime uh or just to
otherwise shift one's biological clock
of course there are other things you can
also do eating early daylight is
something that uh everyone knows I hope
that seeing daylight especially in
morning times is a useful way to combat
jet lag to get your body somehow
adjusted to the fact that the sun is up
even though it thinks that it's supposed
to be nighttime but you know look
whatever works for you everyone is
everyone's biology is different everyone
psychology is different I I suspect that
psychology also matters as we learned
with rosemary Brown uh lots of things
matter there are deeply interconnected
networks of both cells talking to each
other and internal structures in inside
cells which matter for all this stuff so
not surprising to me that different
people react to different
strategies Stevie CPW says if I read the
report correctly 30 billion Suns could
fit into a recently discovered black
hole how does a black hole get to be
that big and when you learn of such
discoveries do you have any emotional
reaction to their awesomeness or is it
more a matter of fact to you so I bet
that what the report said was that the
mass of the black hole was 30 billion
times the mass of the Sun that is
allowed but at the upper level of what
we know for what what we call super
massive black holes which typically
appear at the center of large galaxies
and that the physical size of a 30
billion solar mass black hole would
actually be much smaller than 30 billion
times the size of the sun because
compared to Black Hole the sun is a big
not very dense thing right 30 billion of
them would be much larger than a black
hole so when you squeeze it together
then you get a black hole so but if the
question is how does a black hole get to
be 30 billion times the mass of the Sun
yeah I don't know we don't know you know
keep in mind a large Galaxy will have
trillions of times the mass of the Sun
in total in the mass of the Stars plus
the Dark Matter many trillions of times
the mass of the Sun so 30 billion times
the mass of the Sun is big but it's not
wildly crazy big compared to the size of
the Galaxy it's actually small so there
are very good questions to be asked
about the formation mechanism of these
black holes maybe there's something
weird and fun about primordial physics
or inflation that helps seed these black
holes and galaxies later form around
them or maybe there's just some
efficient mechanism for converting gas
and dust into the black hole to sort of
viral it in there focus it or funnel it
in to the black hole to make them heavy
I don't know this is just not my area
whatsoever so hoping these strong words
can figure that one
out Getty Lee smolen which against my
own advice to myself I'm going to guess
is not someone's real name but that's
okay as a good basian how do you
differentiate belief Hope and Faith well
these are very different words I think
it's pretty easy to differentiate them
no matter what uh faith is a word I just
don't don't use as a good basian people
do use the word if you try to ask them
what they mean by it different people
will have different things to say
different definitions of it some of them
will be a little slippery so i t i just
prefer myself not to use it because it's
one of those words that different people
will insist that you must have in mind
the same definition that they do which I
typically don't so I just I'm not going
to use it belief I I use all the time I
think belief is fine you know I think
that people sometimes think the word
belief should be defined as belief
without evidence but I don't think
that's right you know again when I say
right right and wrong are not words that
one attaches to definitions in any sense
of there being an objectively right
definition to use but I do think that
some definitions make more sense and are
more useful and are carrying more
information and so forth so I I like to
use the word belief when I believe
things and I can believe things with
different levels of credence right I can
believe things because I have good
evidence to believe them I believe that
I had a chicken sandwich for lunch today
because I have a memory of it and I have
no reason to think that that memory is
faulty beliefs would typically have uh
credences attached to them so they're
not yes or no you can you can say well I
I believe that it's probably true that
something is true I think that that's
fine hope is a completely different word
right I mean hope is an expectation for
the future not uh something that you
attach to propositions at the current
moment so I can hope that the
Philadelphia 76ers win the NBA
championship that is not to say that I
believe it will happen certainly not to
say that I have faith in it
happening JC says so Google is shutting
down the podcast application and asking
us to listen to podcasts in YouTube I
don't like YouTube for podcast I
understand that you podcasters receive
less credits for YouTube videos than for
actual podcasts where do you suggest we
go now to listen to you um I don't even
know Google had a I mean probably I knew
that Google had a podcast application
Google as useful as it is it's becoming
less useful and certainly one of the
reasons that as a company it's
losing uh the credit credibility among
customers is they keep offering new
products and then cancelling them after
people get kind of used to them which is
very annoying so I guess that's going to
happen to a podcast reader but there are
lots of podcast readers you can use I
personally use uh overcast for my mobile
devices right for my phone or laptop or
whatever if you go to the mindscape
podcast web page right which is
preposterous universe.com
podcast and you look on
the uh sidebar right over on the right
by the way it's it's actually very nice
to go to the mindscape podcast uh web
page I'm looking at it right now as I
speak and I'm realizing I got to update
this web page a little bit I try to put
advertisers on there and I haven't
updated them in a while sorry
advertisers they send me their money but
I do not always uh serve them correctly
in response so I'm going to have to
update that but um one of the things you
will find on there is a bunch of ways
that you can listen or subscribe iTunes
Stitcher Google there it is Google
podcasts but also Spotify TuneIn podbay
podd pod whatever there's lots of
different ways to do it so you have both
a service that will feed you the RSS
feed and then you also have a reader
like overcast or something like that um
I think you would do much better to just
Google what the different options are or
search for what the different options
are I don't know ask chat GPT what the
different options are rather than ask me
I'm not I'm not I don't tend to be don't
claim to be an expert in comparing
different podcast
readers Ari Mai says is it possible that
at the very center of a black hole is
the same thing as the universe before
the Big Bang well this is one of those
questions I have to sort of um think
about what is being meant here for one
thing if you know a little bit about
black holes the center is probably not
what you're thinking of if you carefully
study what happens inside a black hole
there's a singularity but the
singularity is not at the center The
Singularity is in the future of you when
you fall into the black hole the correct
statement is once you're in the black
hole moving toward the singularity is
moving forward in time so you hit it in
the same way that you hit tomorrow not
in the same way you hit the wall to the
left or right of you the center of the
black hole is whatever made the black
hole if there's there was a star that
collapsed to make the black hole then if
you can get to the center before hitting
the singularity you will see the tiny
squeez together star there if you could
possibly get there so probably what you
mean
is is there something that at the
singularity resembles the universe
before the Big Bang so two things to say
about that one we have no idea what was
the universe before the Big Bang or
whether there was any Universe before
the Big Bang maybe there was that's
something to put a lot of thought into
write papers about think carefully about
I do that other people do that that's an
ongoing thing but the big bang may have
been the beginning it there might not be
any such thing as the universe before
the Big Bang or there may in we just
don't know the other is there's zero
reason in known physics to think that
there's anything beyond the singularity
of the black hole there are reasons to
think that there is no Singularity to
the black hole namely that there's
quantum gravity and the prediction of a
singularity at the center of at the in
the future of the black hole once you're
inside the Event Horizon comes from
classical general relativity and we know
classical general relativity is not
going to be right there's going to be be
something Quantum there probably
something finite in one way or another
we just don't know what exactly that way
is now people have absolutely speculated
about the possibility that when you make
a black hole at the center somehow it
creates a new universe or it it pops
into a new universe or transitions into
a new universe it's a free country you
are welcome to speculate about such
things uh but we don't have any theory
that says that should happen or does
happen or any knowledge of exactly how
it would happen other than waving our
hands a little bit about quantum
mechanics gravity who knows
really Anthony KN says what is the
difference between the wave function
realism of the kind that David Albert
talks about versus Mad Dog everan ISM
yeah so this is one for the experts and
you know by the way um I know that this
is a mixed audience listening to the
amas and sometimes uh for for very
predictable reasons um people Express a
kind of frustration that some of the
answers to some of the questions are not
precisely on their particular level of
knowledge that is to say uh some answers
are too Technical and presume that you
know something about what's going on and
some answers are too simple or like you
heard them before and you don't want to
hear this basic stuff over and over
again what I try to do is calibrate the
answer to the question based on the
question usually from the question and
how it's asked you can figure out
something about how much the person
knows about this stuff how technically
um informed they are about it and you'll
try to answer on that level but also you
know I might be guessing wrong and I I
might be assuming that people have
listened to previous podcasts and stuff
like that so my apologies if I don't get
it exactly right um but also my advice
is you know live with it as as The
Listener um you're going to listen to
some things that are not exactly on your
level some will be below them in terms
of your total knowledge some will be
above them all that's fine you know you
know think about how you would answer it
if it's if it's too simple for you and
sit back and listen if if it's too um
high level for you and think about the
day when it will be too low level for
you because you've learned so much that
you've completely caught up so this
question is a relatively high level
question this is an ongoing sort of
Frontier thing in foundations of physics
wave function realism is something that
David Albert former mindscape guest
talks about other people also talk about
it and it sounds very similar absolutely
to um Mad Dog everettian ISM or just
Hilbert space fundamentalism you will
sometimes hear it called so um this is
something that I have promulgated and
and supported the idea that the right
way to think about the fundamental
nature of physical reality is that it is
something it is physical reality
and it is modeled by a vector in Hilbert
space and that is the right quantum
mechanical lesson to draw the wave
function realism sounds very similar to
that because we often casually trade off
the word Vector in Hilbert space or
Quantum state or state Vector any of
those are equivalent for phrases like
the wave function of the universe and
that's okay if you know what you're
doing but in this case there is a subtle
difference and the subtle difference is
the wave function that David is talking
about is a specific
representation of the physical state
Vector that I would talk about in
particular is a representation in
configuration space so you know that if
you have one particle that has a
position X its wave function is s of X
some complex number for every value of
the position variable if you have
multiple particles with possible
positions X1 X2 X3 at Etc you have one
big wave function that is a function of
X1 X2 and X3 and whatever other
particles you have you can always do
things like change variables you could
for example go to momentum space and
talk about s of P1 P2 P3 or any other
different kinds of things you could work
in the energy igen basis Etc to the Mad
Dog everan who cares what's real is the
vector what's real is not the basis that
you use to express that vector in
there's nothing more real about the
position space basis or configuration
space basis than there is the energy IG
basis or the momentum IG basis or what
have you but to wave function realists
there is that's the difference they want
to say that the set of all the positions
of all the particles which is what
you're building your wave function out
of has some reality to it and that's the
difference and I see no reason to think
that it has any reality to it it doesn't
even really fit very comfortably with
the true fact that modern physics works
with Fields rather than with particles
right uh you can Gussy it up to do that
you can say well it's s the wave
function as a function of all of the
field Profiles In Space Etc but to me or
from my point of view from the Mad Dog
ever edian point of view it is giving
some ontological oomph to good old
ordinary three-dimensional space in ways
that is not really that are not really
um supported by anything that we know in
physics it's convenient but I don't want
to I don't see why we should give it any
uh special preference there's no
difference to me versus a wave function
in position space or momentum space why
is one supposed to be better than the
other I don't know what matters to me is
the overall Vector of course I should
say that means more work for the Mad Dog
ever Edan because we have to explain why
space is so useful right but that's okay
we we do that that's that's part of our
um project for writing
papers only normal person has asks a
priority question in an earlier AMA you
stated that in contrast to Suicide
euthanasia may be allowable which would
indicate that you think there should be
General moral Andor legal prohibition on
suicide at 30 I've come to the
conclusion that number one I'm generally
unhappy due to depression rather than
external variables number two I'm
completely skeptical that I make people
around me happier than if I were to not
exist there are currently living people
who would be saddened by my death but on
some level I feel ultimately hope that I
can find an opportunity to check out
early maybe within 10 years 15 years at
the latest without anyone feeling harmed
which will certainly require certain
behavioral commitments but at least
seems like an objectively non- feudal
goal possibly the only one that is
possible in a world where we have pretty
limited agency to make things better for
others and the second law of
Thermodynamics implies existence will
always be more destructive than
constructive do you think creating and
working toward harm mitigated suicide as
a long-term plan is ethically and
logically sound or would you posit some
objection well this is a tough question
this is a deep one uh I'll try to take
it as seriously as I can here um I I
honestly don't recall in an earlier AMA
saying that in contrast to Suicide
euthanasia may be allowable
uh but maybe I did I don't exactly
remember the specific words I used there
I think that there are two different
things going on more than two but at
least two big big big considerations
here one is uh is there a general
philosophical ethical prohibition
against committing suicide and in that I
would say no I don't think that there is
I think that I would want individual
people to make the ultimate choices
about the fate of their lives to the
extent that that is possible um but the
other thing is that there are practical
considerations here and I can't downplay
them it's much you know it's somewhat
Loosely analogous to the Free Speech
discussion that we had before um the
practicalities matter uh and there are
many practicalities and I'm sure that
you have been exposed to them I'm
probably not telling you anything you
don't know but you know people change
their minds about committing suicide um
things like depression can be dealt with
with some combination of therapy and
medication and things like that and
suicide is one way killing yourself is
not something you can undo there's a
famous story that is told somewhat
jokingly although it's not really
something to joke about Murray gelmon
the famous physicist one of the best
physicists of the 20th century uh when
he was in high school he very seriously
contemplated committing suicide and it
was about when he had been accepted to
go to college at MIT and he told the
joke that uh he he realized that going
to MIT and committing suicide do not
commute which is a physicist way of
saying uh doing one than the other is
not the same as doing the other than the
one you can go to MIT and then commit
suicide but you can't commit suicide and
then go to MIT which is a way of saying
that you things can change um they
change for Murray Gman that doesn't mean
they will change for you I can't make
any promises like that and again I'm
sure that you've heard things like this
before but I have to get them on the
table because they're true and they're
important to keep in mind I would
disagree a little bit with where you say
the second law of Thermodynamics implies
existence will always be more
destructive than constructive that's not
what the second law of Thermodynamics
says the second law says that entropy
increases I started this podcast with
talking about the paper I'm writing with
Scott Aronson about complexity and how
it evolves over time and the point is
that complexity increases even though
entropy is increasing at least for a
while there's some Cosmic Horizon
billions and billions and billions of
years in the future where it's going to
be hard to for complex structures to
persist but right now as far as the laws
of physics are concerned yes entropy is
going up but that does absolutely not
equate to being more destructive there's
all sorts of things things that can be
built can be creative created can be
brought into existence that have never
existed before there is absolutely uh a
huge amount of room for human creativity
and
constructive gifts to the world that can
come from people doing good things
despite the second law of Thermodynamics
being at work so I don't agree with the
general idea that you know life is not
worth living or anything like that to me
you know life is very worth living I I
very much recognize that other people
everyone has their own circumstances I I
respect that I'm not going to tell you
that your life in particular has to be
worth living and you're making a mistake
and I know better than you do because I
don't but I don't think that it's right
to look at these sort of cosmic
Tendencies or laws of physics as
justifications or arguments in favor of
this that whichever position you might
have uh exactly because of the finality
of it because of the ultimate nature of
it I I think that it is absolutely
sensible to be as as super duper
cautious and thoughtful as you can
possibly be when it comes to questions
like your own life for whatever to do
not just suicide but even you know risky
behaviors and then things like that I
mean you only get one life I don't think
that there's any afterlife or anything
like that so there's an enormous
presumption against ending it um unless
you really really really really really
really don't see any other way
especially because as you say there are
people who would be saddened by your
death uh you hope to make that not true
down the road in some number of years
that that sounds hard for me to see how
that could happen I think that there
will always be people um who are
saddened when other people uh their Liv
end one way or another so you know I
again
philosophically I think that it should
be possible uh to do something like that
but the practicalities are so large and
the and I don't quite align with some of
your philosophical statements in the
question so I would you know if if
nothing else suggest working as hard as
you legitimately can to give a sincere
thought to other possible strategies out
there I'm not the person to be uh
listening to about these things I'm not
a professional in any way you should not
take this as medical advice I'm just
giving you my AMA level opinion which is
not even you know very carefully
researched or or anything like that so
these are tough questions I sympathize
with your situation um we don't as a as
a society make these questions very easy
uh we don't make them uh we don't talk
about them in an adult way you know one
of the first podcasts I did with Megan
Rosenblum was on um death with dignity
and usually that's in the context of
euthanasia but it's you know it's
euthanasia that obviously the person has
signed off on right um usually in cases
of severe disease or something like that
and and and there I do think I would say
everything I just said about the
seriousness of the issue and the
importance of uh really thinking things
through but if you have a terminal
disease then I'm I'm more on the side of
you know do what is going to be most
comfortable for you and and pain-free
whereas if you think that you're
physically pretty put together Etc then
the presumption I think goes the other
way but you know as I said everyone's
situation is different so all I can do
is wish you my best of luck now I'm
going to group together two questions
Robert Gren
uh asks a priority question is there any
Credence to the idea that dark matter is
space that exists at a level of higher
dimensionality so we cannot see or
interact with it and Lars wallart says
we say there are four fundamental forces
although Einstein showed us that
gravitation is merely a distortion of
SpaceTime could the other three forces
also be considered to be just
distortions of dimensions and might
these Dimensions be correlated to the
extra Dimensions referred to in string
Theory as curled up Dimensions so both
of these um have to do with you know
extra dimensions and their Dynamics in
some way okay so for Robert's question I
I want to try to figure out what exactly
is meant by dark matter is space that
exists at a higher a level of higher
dimensionality I think that the
respectable version of that that has
been explored by physicists is if we
have extra dimensions of space and they
are curled up
then you can have particles with
momentum in the direction of the extra
Dimensions particles that are like doing
little Loops in the extradimensional
dimensions and how those particles
appear to us is just as regular
particles but with more mass than they
would otherwise have so they're heavier
so these are called kuta Klein particles
after kuta and Klein who invented the
idea or pioneered the idea anyway of
extra dimensions of space so so but
really they're particles at the end of
the day so I'm I'm thinking that this is
maybe not what you have in mind um so
yes you can imagine particles that
somehow move in extra dimensions and
that affects their properties but not in
a very fundamental way not in a very
profound and different way ultimately
they're just particles with some masses
um but the point is that that's what you
want to be the dark matter the dark
matter that we know of we know a lot
about its properties actually we know
that it doesn't collide with itself um
we at least not noticeably so we know
that it's cold so it doesn't move near
the speed of light we know its density
we know its initial distribution in the
early universe and we know a lot about
how it has evolved since then and so on
and so on and in all of these ways it
acts like a particle like a good old
particle weakly interacting with some
Mass so I wouldn't
Advocate working too hard to invent
models that are nothing at all particle
like right you want to invent models
that just reproduce ordinary particle
behaviors they might be interestingly
different in some ways but when you
think about you know both both questions
ask are asking about could dark matter
be some feature of space itself I don't
know exactly know what that would mean
but I it would strike me as weird if a
feature of space itself had all of the
particle-like behavior that we normally
attribute to Dark Matter so it's not a
natural or easy kind of thing to think
about although you know maybe at the end
of the day you can always just say
maybe Brian Mapes says do you have more
specific ideas or examples about how to
usefully tally macroscale
entropy parenthesis complexity
separately from the abyss of molecular
entropy which increases by the second
law inspired by the coffee figure in the
big picture by the way in the big
picture I plot the coffee versus cream
example that Scott arenson and I are
trying to finish our paper about that's
what Brian is referring to here inspired
by that and your Berkeley colloquium
last year I'm trying to do this for
mesoscale patterns or configurations of
clouds and weather scenes which I hope
can be a natural framework for
evolutionary theory of why naively
unlikely but energy efficient
multicellular storms are so common I
mean the short answer is no many of
these words you used do not fit together
to match anything that is going on in my
mind right now so I'm not quite sure
what you have in mind so I I don't have
any specific ideas or examples along
these lines the cloud example I should
say is very different than what we
studied because as I mentioned the whole
point of what Scott and I and our
collaborators are studying is that we're
looking at closed systems if you have
open systems that is to say systems that
are driven by forces from the outside
systems that interact with the rest of
the world then you can sustain
complexity for a long time you can have
turbulent systems you know the Great Red
Spot on Jupiter not to mention all the
rest of the fun bits of complexity in
Jupiter's atmosphere these are driven by
dynamical processes and energy is being
pumped into them and in statistical
mechanics we have what are called
non-equilibrium steady States and that
is something that uh we don't know a lot
about them but you know they they are
known to exist and people study them and
and so forth there's several famous
examples of things like these uh playing
important roles and so clouds would be
one example I mean clouds are not closed
systems clouds very much interact with
the world around them so if you just
kept pumping in the right kind of energy
a cloud could exist forever whereas in
what Scott and I were studying you are
tending toward equilibrium since you're
not pumping in anything from the the
outside world you will eventually that
cream and that coffee were just reach
equilibrium and then stop you know
there's nothing more macroscopically
that's going to happen so we're looking
for sort of
self-generated complexity not not
complexity that is parasitic on energy
being pushed in from
outside Liam mccardy says why is there
so little scatter in the bionic Tully
Fisher relation I saw you say in a
recent interview with Brian Green that
there's overwhelming evidence for dark
matter but I struggled to understand why
there would be so little scatter in the
dark matter Paradigm and I've been
struck by the fact that Mond predicts
exactly a relation that matches the data
I know mon fails for Galaxy cluster
Dynamics and more but I'm curious to
hear your thoughts on why it predicts as
much as it does despite being
incorrect well so this is again an
expert level question let me try to back
up and uh and and fill in the Tully fish
relation is a relationship between the
the mass or the density I guess I forget
of a spiral galaxy and the velocity that
it has um the ASM totic rotation
velocity um and this is a interesting
important astrophysical empirical
relationship uh that's a little bit
different for spiral galaxies and
elliptical galaxies Etc but nevertheless
it is there I don't think that the
scatter is very small I think there's
pretty noticeable scatter in the Tully
Fisher relation but um this it's it's an
interesting case I'm answering the
question because not not because I have
an interesting answer to it but because
it raises interesting questions within
this field um there are people who
Advocate against dark matter and in
favor of modified gravity uh Mond the
theory put forward by modai mgram is uh
a favorite example of an alternative to
dark matter and M make certain very
specific predictions and the Tully
Fisher relation is one of them it it
explains that quite well whereas in the
cold Dark Matter Paradigm um the tul
Fisher relation and other there are
other features of phenomenological
Galaxy um uh structure and so forth that
are not obviously predicted by the cold
Dark Matter Paradigm but the point is it
is completely possible that we just
haven't predicted them yet the relations
that become important in these galaxies
that mon purports to explain are always
in the regime where the dark matter by
itself is not doing the work it's
exactly where the dark matter and the
ordinary bionic matter are sort of both
important at the same time and bionic
matter despite the fact that it is what
we know about from experiments and
observations and so forth is actually
much harder harder to dynamically model
than dark matter because dark matter is
just collisionless it's just feeling
gravity that's it but bionic matter
feels magnetic fields and uh just light
from stars and Supernova explosions and
there's all sorts of interactions and
it's very very complicated and no one
claims to know exactly what's going on
so the fact that there are features in
galaxies that are compatible with the
cold Dark Matter Theory but not directly
predicted by it to me is the least
surprising thing in the world I would
just expect that to be the case given
how complicated astrophysics and Magneto
hydrodynamics are whereas as you say in
the in the question um M fails for
Galaxy cluster Dynamics it fails for the
cosmic microwave background it's not
that it doesn't quite make a prediction
it makes a prediction and the prediction
is wrong so I I honestly struggle to see
why anyone sees uh similarity here or uh
you know a a kind of equivalence you
know one theory has failed the other
theory has not yet answered every
question you can ask about it those are
not equally big problems when the theory
fails you should move on when the theory
doesn't yet answer all the questions you
can ask of it you work harder to answer
those questions so I think that you know
astrophysically by all means put work
into understanding the rotation curves
of spiral galaxies and the Tully Fisher
relation all these things but to think
that their evidence against Dark Matter
uh just seems a little weird to me to be
honest Henry Jacobs says in your recent
interview with Brendan Nyan he expressed
skepticism about the impact of filter
bubbles did this alter your perception
on the issue not that much but you know
um it was priced in for me already like
I read Brendan nian stuff and other
people's stuff I think that it's another
example of life being complicated okay
um there in the some at some point
people started saying oh now that we
have social media you can have filter
bubbles you could only be exposed to
opinions you like but it was always
going to be more complicated than that
and guess what it is more complicated
than that I mean Zep
Tuki expressed similar thoughts years
ago when she was on the podcast um and
someone else did I I'm forgetting who
maybe not on the podcast maybe something
I read somewhere else but the point is
most people are in fact exposed to all
sorts of different opinions they just
don't listen oh maybe it was Yugo
Mercier actually uh people do see U
opinions and facts that go against their
particular belief systems but they're
really good at ignoring
them that's the problem more than the
filter bubble problem so um I think that
I'm on Brendan's side with that but I
don't think that it was it was it was
not that new to me uh the details of
course are always interesting and useful
when you talk to someone who really
knows what they're talking
about Jason richiardi says in your
podcast with yeni Choy you stated when
people say alignment in the context of
AI they mean aligning the values of
human beings with the values of AI which
sounds like a good thing to do but then
again I'm not sure that AI has values
I worry there's a category mistake going
on here Choy responded humans have
diverse values depending on different
cultures but we also just have personal
choice so I believe in value pluralism
well we just have to respect a lot of
different values and the question is
what does that even mean to align to
diverse values I agree value pluralism
would be the right approach to AI
alignment but I'm wondering the answer
to the question in her response if you
want to take a stab well I don't not
sure I want to take a daab actually
because the point I was making was a
little bit different I probably should
have followed up on this better than I
did in real time um to say human beings
have diverse values sure yes I
completely agree with that that's fine
and therefore that is a challenge when
aligning ai's values with our values but
my question was does AI even have
values it has something it does
something but we are being
anthropomorphic when we talk about AI as
a thing that has values right that the
or at least in principle it is not
completely clear to me that the concept
of a value is something that makes sense
for an AI to have maybe it does or maybe
it will someday or something like that
but we shouldn't just talk that talk
without giving serious thought to
whether or not the words were saying
make any sense the question to me is not
to which values do we align it is does
it even make sense to talk about the
values that an AI would have in order to
align them with whatever we might want
them to be I actually think that it
won't be that hard if the AIS do have
values or there comes to be some
pragmatic understanding of what it means
to talk about AI having values
to give them values you know even though
different human beings do um treat each
other differently do have different
ideas about what the values should be
Etc that doesn't seem to be actually to
me the main stumbling block we can train
the AIS to be kind of you know blandly
nice to each other and nice to human
beings and that's fine if if we can
teach them anything at all but I I think
that we're in danger of making a huge
mistake of taking the word values that
we use in the context of human beings
and blly extending them to cover
artificial intelligences I I don't think
that we know or for that matter it's not
not anything special about the word
values I think you can say thing say the
same thing about the word knowledge for
example the AIS we've created in neural
networks machine learning deep learning
models think in a very different way as
far as we can tell than human beings
think so we have trained them and
designed them and built them to sound
like human beings therefore we tend to
gloss over the fact that their
underlying thinking processes are wildly
different than ours so that's why I
would want to be at least very very
cautious about using language that takes
human qualities that we attribute to our
thinking and our values and so forth and
mindlessly apply them to AIS
Johan Fulk says priority question can a
pair of particles be in a superposition
of entangled and not entangled are and
are there any ways of doing a Bell's
inequality like test to test this well
sure I mean no problem you can have two
particles that are in a state of being
entangled you can have two particles the
same two particles could be in a state
of not being entangled and you can
superimpose them that's what quantum
mechanics is all about Quantum states
can always be added together to make a
superp position the way that we would
talk about it if we actually had that is
not to say that the particles are in a
superp position of entangled or non and
non-entangled rather we would just say
they are not maximally entangled
entanglement is not a yes or no question
it's there's a degree of entanglement so
if you think about two spins for example
right and the usual example that people
have is the spins are anti-aligned with
each other so spin up and spin down plus
spin down and spin up that would be an
entangled State what would be an
unentangled State well if you knew the
first one was spin up and you knew the
second one was spin down that would be
unentangled right because you know both
of them they're both completely known
and there's no nothing new that you
learn about the Second Spin by measuring
the first so take the entangled state
which is spin up and spin down plus spin
down and spin up and just add a little
bit add Epsilon spin up spin down so
then you get unequal contributions from
spin up spin down and spin down spin up
and suddenly you have a superposition of
entangled and non-entangled it's just
that you've lowered the entanglement a
little bit are there ways to test it I
mean it's always a little bit
complicated but the the rough answer is
going to be yes uh you know if you know
anything about Bells inequality you know
that you can't test it with just a
single measurement it's an inequality
that is statistical in nature so you
have to do a whole bunch of tests but
you could do exactly the same thing for
whatever Quantum State you
wanted Natalie lines says can you
explain a bit about the emergence of
SpaceTime from quantum mechanics and
your paper space from Hilbert space I
just serendipitously came across it and
am fascinated by the
concept yeah so you know uh I mean I'm
answering this question for two reasons
because I've talked about this a lot I
did solo podcast if you're interested
Natalie uh Gravity from quantum
mechanics or something like that and
there I go into great detail about it um
but I wanted to answer it both because I
love it when people serendipitously come
across research papers that I written
and are curious but also because I
realize that at the philosophy level I
am not yet doing the best possible job
of explaining what's going on and I
don't mean that in terms of my rhetoric
or speaking or writing about it I mean
my understanding of it you know we're
talking about emergence and I talk about
emergence a lot it's absolutely Central
to how I think about the world I talk
about it a lot in the big picture but
there are some you know uh nagging
philosophical worries about how well we
understand the basic concept of
emergence so I'm I'm going to apologize
here because I forget which questions I
am including here in the AMA and which I
had to delete for reasons of of time and
space but one thing to mention about
emergence is the word one of the reasons
why the word is not very good is because
it gives you the impression of a process
happening over time right when uh you
emerge from the pool and dry yourself
off you were in the pool and then you
emerged from it that is not the idea of
emergence that we have here the real
idea we have at the base level is a
match between two different kinds of
patterns okay the example I'm always
having in the back of my mind is the
emergence of gases and fluids from atoms
so we have atoms and the gas in the room
that I'm speaking to you from right now
that I can speak of as a gas as the air
in the room it has a temperature it has
a pressure it has all that stuff or I
can speak of it in terms of the uh
actual atoms and molecules of air and so
there's a par parallel set of different
vocabularies a vocabulary of atoms with
positions and velocities a vocabulary of
a fluid with pressure and density and
things like that and there's a
relationship between these different
vocabularies that's what emergence is to
me as a relationship not an arbitrary
relationship a relationship that
preserves the relevant features so for
example I know that if I have a certain
temperature of the air in the room and a
certain certain density and things like
that uh if I just leave the room to its
own devices one can predict how the
temperature and density will evolve over
time and I could make that prediction
either at the level of all the
individual atoms and molecules or the
level of the gas but there are you know
some hanging questions about exactly how
that happens is it unique Etc when does
it happen and so forth so I need to do
better at my way of explaining what I
think of as emergence but the rough idea
is exactly that kind of parallelism but
now between a Quantum State and space or
space as in part of space time right so
in general relativity space has a
geometry it has a dimensionality it's
three dimensions in the world that we
know and it has a geometry at least if
you take a slice of space time to make
space it will have some induced geometry
from the shape of that slice and the
features like the geometry and how it
changes over time we are saying
match certain features of the underlying
Quantum State you can extract from the
underlying Quantum State the same
patterns of Behavior Uh both description
at any one moment and changes in the
description over time that you would
have uh if you just had a
straightforward SpaceTime description
that's what we mean by emergence you can
locate the pattern uh I'm using pattern
because Dan Dennett famously wrote a
paper called real patterns where he
explains this this rough kind of
philosophy although again I still think
that there's more work to be done but I
think he got the basic idea right
there's a matching of these patterns
that's what you mean by emergence that's
what we're looking for hap happening in
the quantum State and physical space and
the way it happens is with
entanglement different parts of hilber
space are entangled with each other and
they have the right kind of entanglement
and the right pattern of entanglement to
match what we know is supposed to happen
from Good Old space and good old Quantum
field Theory um it hasn't completely
happened yet you know we put a lot of it
together but there's still work to be
done there so let's see how it
goes James Tyler K says from what I
understand in Quantum field Theory every
particle is really just an exitation
within its field and there's a field for
each type of particle however I've also
heard that at high enough energy levels
the electromagnetic force the weak
nuclear force and the strong nuclear
force merge into one force does this
mean that the fields that represent
these forces actually merge into a
single field or is it that the
excitations in the fields become
indistinguishable or is it something
else
entirely I think it's closest to the
last one the excitations in the fields
become indistinguishable there's a
little bit of vocabulary issue here as
as there often is in these situations
when we talk about how many fields we
have so for example in good old strong
strong interactions I don't know if
that's good old for you or not but the
strong interactions are something the
particle physicists understand pretty
well you may have heard that there are
eight different kinds of gluons in the
strong
interactions so the question Aris and
that's true so the question arises do we
have a single gluon field that can
vibrate in eight different ways or do we
have eight different gluon fields right
to be super clear nobody cares about the
answer to this question you just have to
figure out what way you're going to talk
ahead of time and the real point is that
in these theories called Grand unified
theories which are entirely speculative
right now we don't know whether they're
true or not in which electromagnetism
weak nuclear force and the strong
nuclear force merge into one force at
very high energies it would be like the
eight different gluons except there' be
more of them there' be a bunch of
different gauge bons all of which were
were similar to each other all of which
were basically indistinguishable from
each other um which you could call one
field one grand unified cuge field or
you could call it you know a set of
different fields that were all similar
to each other and could be Trad off for
each other it doesn't matter what
language you use what happens when the
grand unified symmetry breaks in these
theories which may or may not be true is
that those different parts of the single
Grand unified field start behaving
differently some of them get masses some
of them couple to quarks some of them
don't and you know they become what we
now call the strong interacting gluons
the weakly interacting w and z bosons
the electromagnetic Photon there's an
intermediate step of course because
before you split off into enm and the
weak Force those gauge bons are unified
together that's a more complic ated
story cuz they're not super duper
unified but that's basically the idea at
super high energies if these theories
are right all of those gauged bosons
look exactly the same and they only
differentiate once you have that
symmetry
breaking Matt Rogers asks a priority
question in his book review of
incomplete nature Dan Dennett said the
Terren Deacon's theory of emergence and
specifically how mind emerges from
matter is the best theory on the topic
he's ever read since emergence is an
area that you care about I was wondering
if you are familiar with Terence
Deacon's theory of emergence if so then
what do you think about it would you be
willing to do a podcast interview with
him as a guest so we can hear you agree
or disagree with him in public so I know
Terry Deacon a little bit uh he was a
participant in the workshop that I
organized moving naturalism forward you
can find his his uh contributions there
on YouTube we have all the YouTube
videos there um and I think he's a very
smart guy doing very interesting things
that that are uh close clly related to
things that I care about um but I'm not
an expert on what he says so you know
look this is the this is the dangerous
thing about asking priority questions
usually if you ask a question are you
familiar with X and I don't answer it
it's because my answer is no I am not
familiar with X so I'm just not familiar
enough with his theory to say anything
uh very much about it as far as having
him on the podcast goes I have a very
policy of never commenting Pro or con
about having people on the podcast
because there's a whole bunch of reasons
why they might not want to come on the
podcast I mean maybe I've already
invited them and they're going to appear
in the future or maybe I have invited
them and they've said no or maybe I have
some reason to think they would be a bad
guest or maybe they're just too busy who
knows but I think it's unfair to my
guests my actual guests or prospective
guests to talk about their suitability
as guests before they actually ever
appear on the
podcast Paul Ki says why is the topic of
climate change so politically polarized
in the USA we also have conservative
political parties over here in Europe
the present governing party in the UK is
actually called the conservative party
but all these parties accept the
scientific basis of anthropogenic
climate change yet in the US it seems to
be split along Republican Democrat party
lines which seems most unhelpful I think
it is most unhelpful that it's
absolutely Ely true and I think it's a
sort of kind of singular pathology of
the United States and you have to
understand you know when the us. is
doing one thing and the rest of the
world is doing the other thing don't try
to understand the rest of the world
better try to understand what's weird
about the United States and there are
many things that are weird about the
United States and very often this is
going to sound very strange because the
question is about climate change very
often it comes down to race and slavery
and the history of the United States
most particularly the Civil War the
Civil War was the unique event that
really made the United States just
different than everywhere else and what
I mean by that this would be a topic for
you know and I'm not a super expert here
so feel free to disagree if you want
this would be a topic for a much longer
discussion with a real expert but we had
this thing in the United States where
you know there was a split between the
south and north and and there was an
economic split in the early days the
north was more Industrial The South was
more agricultural Etc and of course
unmistakably the South had slavery and
all of those facts kind of mixed up with
each other right I mean the slavery it
not it was not uncoincidentally it sorry
it was not coincidental that the part of
the country that had slavery was also
the agricultural part Etc and for
various reasons it became the poorer
part you know if you look at which
states have the highest per capita
income uh which states have the best
universities and things like that it is
uh if you go back to the states that
were there before the Civil War it's the
northern states not the southern states
and so there was this weird mixture of
poor people in the South being resentful
of the north because of the Civil War
and things like that a perception that
they were looked down upon um that was
very
cultural based not particularly
class-based or or income based um that
absolutely drives a lot of American
politics so there are the point is this
gets into
identifications with political groups
that have salience in the United States
that have no analog in other countries
so the Republican Party in the United
States is this bizarre Coalition of
super wealthy business people and super
poor people who are less educated than
average uh more driven by resentment
than average more racist than average uh
again all these are on average they're
shining counter examples of course but
if you tell people in the United States
the average Trump voter the median Trump
vote I don't know if it's the mean of
the meeting to be honest so I shouldn't
say but uh in a very sensible way of
slicing it the average Trump voter had a
higher income than the
average um Biden voter for example or
Hillary Clinton voter they would be
surprised because like the stereotypical
Trump voter is you know poor and
uneducated and whatever but it's this
weird Coalition that we have that you
know there and there's some of that in
other countries too but it's it's much
more pronounced here in the United
States than elsewhere and so what this
has to do with climate change is there
are a bunch of kind of cultural Le
that are important in the United States
that the game theory politicians can
figure out I can take this issue and I
can excite my base with it because they
feel like the world's against them and
it's and they get very resentful about
it and and so forth um there are very
very wealthy people who uh own
businesses and so forth who don't want
political action taken to amarate
climate change because it would cut into
their bottom line and there are very
very poor people who think that the uh
liberal Elites from the coasts and the
North and the universities are trying to
take away their way of life and you know
they're these people are sort of in
class terms on opposite sides but they
are in the same political party in a way
that is just more obvious in the United
States than anywhere else so there's no
logical sensible reason for people to be
against fixing climate change any more
than there is sensible reasons for
people to be against vaccinations or
anything like that um but they go
together in a sort of cultural identity
sense that leads to some bizarre kind of
bizarre bedfellows and kind of bizarre
outcomes and it's much more complicated
than that but I'm just trying to help
out if you're not uh a United States
citizen try to figure out why the United
States is so weird in so many ways you
know this ALS helps to explain why
healthc care uh is so bizarre here in
the United States you know various other
things go back to our very weird kind of
unique
history Christian Hoffman says I would
like to know what the set of things that
Quantum fluctuations can produce is it
true that at every moment in time and
for every possible matter distribution
in space there is a branch of the wave
function however small in weight that
contains that distribution I believe you
did say that charge is conserved in all
branches so that would put a Le at least
one constraint on the matter content I
think this is a complicated question to
be super precise about but the overall
impression one should have um is not
that hard to get namely no it is not
true that Quantum fluctuations can just
produce anything Quantum fluctuations
produce what the schinger equation
allows
for that in many worlds or in quantum
mechanics more generally etc etc Etc no
matter what version of quantum mechanics
you like the shinger equation tells you
what's going to happen at least with
certain probabilities and it never says
everything will happen it says certain
things will happen with some
probabilities the probabilities might be
zero for example the probability of any
transition where the total electric
charge changes is exactly zero but there
might be other cases where the
probability is exactly zero so even if
there might be a whole lot of cases
where the probability is small but not
quite zero I think that the intuition
you should have is very much not
anything could happen it very much is
certain things happen and certain things
don't it's what the shinger equation
allows for that
matters Omi says if we were to ever find
a theory that would unify gr and qft do
you think the equation for it would be
something short and elegant like the
energy Mass equivalence or do you think
it would fill up pages with lengthy if
then else type
scenarios you know it's a reasonable
question I think it would be short and
elegant it's not a perfectly
well-defined question because as many
people have pointed out overall you can
always come up with clever
notation so that even the most
complicated uh equation becomes simple
you know you have some very very
complicated equation you move all the
terms to the left hand side and you call
it X and then on the right hand side you
have zero and so the equation is x
equals 0 all of the details are hidden
in the definition of X and you could do
likewise even if it's not um a single
equation even if it is then a list of if
then else type scenarios but that's
cheating I think we kind of all know
that is cheating I think that there's I
don't know if there's a way to phrase
this question in a better defined way to
be honest but the spirit of it is is
there's kind of a unified thing that the
world is and a unified way that that
thing behaves right and maybe it shows
up in different ways but there's is
there an underlying single elegant
behavior for this stuff um in my
naturalism class that I'm teaching right
now we're just reading Nancy cartright
who is a philosopher of science who very
much believes the opposite she uh
defends an idea of a patchwork physics
where you're just going to need
different
language and different concepts to
discuss different kinds of physics
different kinds of physical stuff I just
don't see any motivation for that
honestly I think that all the entire
history of physics has been um moved
towards Simplicity and
unification there's no on the other
other hand there's no principled
argument that it has to keep going that
way so it's absolutely possible that the
final Theory would be a complete mess
but if I were to bet I would bet on it
being pretty
simple Chris V says could you briefly
talk about the Fineman lectures on
physics if I wanted to build toward a
working knowledge base from forces to
Quantum field theory in my free time
would you recommend them as a good place
to start no I would not the final
lectures are great once you've already
learned physics because they're
extraordinarily insightful they use
clever pedagogical techniques and things
like that but they're a little quirky
and they're quite high level
so it would be very very difficult I
think for most people to learn physics
for the first time starting from the
Fineman lectures and also they don't go
that far right I mean they were very
explicitly aimed at the first three
semesters of an undergraduate physics
Majors
education so they don't do Quantum field
they don't even purport to try to do
Quantum field Theory or general
relativity or anything like that um the
books I've just written try to do
exactly that so you could try those but
you know that's a it's it's not supposed
to be a working understanding in in the
sense of solving problems if that's what
you mean by working you're supposed to
understand the concepts from reading my
books um but I would absolutely
recommend having them around the finary
lectures if you were learning from
something else and wanted an extra
reference to compare
to Nita s says I'm curious as to how you
process reality how does this thought
make you feel that all we can retrieve
from reality is that we share entropy
AKA life cycle with our loved ones does
it generate fear confusion anger nothing
it feels like until we find the theory
of quantum gravity and going Beyond
Quantum field Theory something big is
missing from our understanding of
reality well there's a lot going on here
let me try to at least comment on it
um so you say uh all we can retrieve
from reality is that we share entropy
AKA life cycle with our loved ones so
number one I'm not sure what is meant by
sharing entropy with our loved ones uh
both we and our loved ones increase the
entropy of the universe uh and I also
don't know what is meant to say entropy
AKA life cycle that I'm not quite sure
how that connection is made there this
is like in the vicinity of something
that I think is very important and
fascinating and deserves to be better
understood than it is about how in the
process of increasing ENT ropy human
beings do things like form memories and
communicate and share information all of
this is highly tied up with entropy
increasing but it isn't simply reduced
to entropy increasing and then you're
asking um does these facts generate fear
confusion anger nothing yeah I mean I
would say nothing I mean I would say
maybe it generates intellectual
curiosity I want to understand how it
works but if you read the big picture I
try to be very explicit here that
we should understand the world at
different levels the levels need to be
compatible with each other you can't
have one level of understanding that is
just in conflict or in contradiction
with another level but every level is
autonomous you can talk about the world
at that level so when I talk about human
beings my loved ones Etc I'm just not
thinking about entropy and atoms and
stuff like that those are not the
relevant Concepts to use finally you say
uh until we have a theory of quantum
gravity something big is missing in
understanding of reality yeah sure
quantum gravity is missing that's that
counts as something big but again it's
not going to affect our human level of
comprehension there's nothing big in
fundamental physics that is going to
change who we are as human
beings Leen bont says I want to better
understand emergence me too leand so
we're on the same page here is the claim
life emerged from a soup any more
rigorous insightful informative specific
explanatory or scientific than the claim
there were chemicals and then a miracle
happened and now there is life so first
thing is that's not emergence that is
exactly the misunderstanding of the word
emergence I was warning about a couple
questions before when we say life emerg
from a chemical soup that is not the
idea of emergence that we have in mind
when we're talking about the emergence
of one higher level description from a
lower level description the Life coming
from from chemical soup is supposed to
be a specific physical process playing
out over time in terms of whether or not
that suggestion is more rigorous
insightful Etc yes absolutely it is much
more rigorous than a miracle happened
why because we can study it because we
can figure out what the process was
because we know what the basic
ingredients are we know what the
underlying laws are so we can do science
to it where as we cannot do much science
to the claim that a miracle happened and
now there is life that's a much less
helpful
perspective Eric deidi says we've heard
of the technological singularity but do
you think there's such a thing as a
cultural Singularity or even just a hard
cap on how complex human culture can
become as we accumulate more and more
cultural artifacts in recorded history
no but I don't think there's a
technological singularity either I mean
there let's back up it depends on what
you really mean by a hard cap there is
of course a
cosmological uh upper bound to how long
civilizations and people can survive you
know how much entropy and information we
can we can talk about but we are so so
so so far away from that that in no
practical terms is that at all relevant
uh and I think that the talk of the
technological singularity is entirely
silly uh based on plotting things that
have no numerical values to them and
then scaring yourself into thinking that
something's going to happen there are
phase transitions there are moments
there are tipping points where things
happen where things change dramatically
and irrevocably and something like that
could happen but to think of it as a
hard cap is I think the wrong way of
thinking about uh what is the future of
human
culture physics kitten says I know that
relativity treats gravity as the
curvature of SpaceTime and I understand
how that works in examples like the
orbit of planets around the Sun but how
do I make sense of a curvature of
SpaceTime interpretation in the case of
Tides which I think of as being caused
by gravitational attraction of the
oceans on the side of the earth near the
moon what space time is curved and is
there a relativistic way to describe
what is going on yeah there's 100% a
relativistic way to describe what is
going on and I I'm not quite sure where
the confusion arises here because it's
kind of clear in my mind so I apologize
if my answer isn't helpful to you but
the SpaceTime that is curved is the
SpaceTime through which the earth and
its oceans are moving it the reason why
it is curved is because the moon and the
sun to some extent are curving it and
that curvature shows up as what we would
have thought of pre- Relativity as the
force due to gravity and it's exactly
the same I mean there's no difference in
the solar system here in on Earth anyway
between the effective force of gravity
that Newton would have predicted and the
effective force of gravity that general
relativity predicted it's just that the
explanation for it is different the
curvature of SpaceTime SpaceTime is
curved in a very particular way that
matches on exactly to the Newtonian
gravitational potential so the workings
of things like tides are no different
whatsoever in general relativity than in
Newtonian gravity um there's other
things that can happen like
gravitational waves that Newtonian
gravity doesn't have room for but the
good old Newtonian phenomena are a
subset of all the possible things that
general relativity accounts
for Tomas gajos says can you talk about
where the idea of dark energy comes from
and what evidence supports it you've
talked about the evidence for existence
and properties of dark matter in your
recent solo episode but Dark Energy
wasn't covered in that much detail and
I'd love to learn more about that too
you know kind of there's less to say
about Dark Energy in two senses one is
um unlike dark matter where we have many
different theories that could be right
but we just don't know which one is
right for Dark Energy we basically have
one really really really good theory and
a bunch of less good theories the one
really good theory is of the dark energy
is the cosmological constant it is just
uh an energy in the vacuum an energy
that is inherent in empty space itself
it's the same amount of energy in every
cubic centimeter of space an idea going
back to Einstein we talk about it in
slightly different ways in the modern
world but it basically is that idea and
you can posit this as Einstein did he
later gave up on it but he didn't
completely forget about it it sort of
was always lurking in the back of the
minds of cosmologists as they tried to
confront various observations that came
on finally in 1998 we found very good
evidence that the universe is Accel
accelerating that is exactly what you
would expect if about 70% of the energy
density of the universe were this dark
energy stuff this vacuum energy stuff
the problem is no one really expected it
I mean people had absolutely been
thinking about it but no one would have
bet you 50/50 that it was there so we
were surprised and the reason why we
were we were surprised is because it
seems very very unnatural that you would
have exactly that amount of dark energy
rather than some other amount that's a
longer conversation I don't want to get
into right now but because we were wrong
about the expectations there um we are
trying to be cautious and people said
well even though we have a perfectly
good theory that fits all the data the
cosmal constant we should still be
cautious so we should allow for
something that is dynamical something
that is not completely constant and we
do that and we try to test it but guess
what all the tests are saying that if
there is any dynamic dyamics to it it's
very hard to notice practically zero
just what you would expect if it's not
dynamical at all so people like me have
proposed modifying gravity to get rid of
the Dark Energy but it doesn't fit as
well as the original vacuum energy idea
so the smart money is it's just vacuum
energy it's just the cosmal constant if
it's not there will be some data that
will come in and will change our
minds Stefan bernegger says how is
entropy defined in an open system like
the universe where total energy within
an expanding volume is increasing and
where gravity is ordering matter well it
doesn't matter any none of those things
matter if as long as you have some
distribution of particles for example
once you have Fields it does become
trickier because Fields can do an
infinite number of things very easily
but let's stick with just particles then
you have a distribution function right
you have a
probability uh that there will be a
particle with a certain position and a
certain velocity call this F okay the
distribution function the probability f
is a function of X and P the positions
and the momenta of the particles then
there's an equation f equals minus the
integral of f log f s sorry entropy
equals minus the integral of f log F
that's it it's basically a way of saying
how tightly constrained that probability
distribution is a probability
distribution that is very very narrowly
concentrated in some region is said to
have low entropy and one that is spread
out all over phase space is said to have
high entropy so this idea of entropy
that I just told you about arose from a
phenomenological thermodynamic
understanding from the 1850s or whatever
before we knew about atoms and molecules
and so forth and then the definition of
entropy was something that only applied
to equilibrium situations but now since
the 1870s honestly we can do better than
that there's no reason to assume
equilibrium Shan Bert says how do we
Collide such small particles in
accelerators I can hardly throw a
baseball in a straight line I can't
imagine the Precision needed to collide
two protons moving at 099 C uh they move
a lot faster than 99c at least uh
relatively speaking
9999999999 C something like that but I
get the question and the answer is
roughly speaking you just throw a lot of
particles at each other this is what is
called the luminosity in a particle
accelerator so you have a beam of
protons for example and you try to make
the beam as thin and as focused as
possible so the density of particles is
as high as you can get and then you zoom
them around at High Velocity so you zoom
a zoom a sorry you zoom a huge number
number of particles around a ring in
your particle accelerator very very fast
and push two of those uh beams of
particles at opposite directions in the
middle of a particle detector most of
them do indeed just go right by each
other but sometimes you see a
spectacular Collision um it just work
out the numbers there's a lot of them
there and by the way it's tricky right
you think about it I'm trying to have a
beam of particles it's not a continuous
beam it comes in bunches because I need
to turn magnets on and off really
quickly to give them a little nudge to
give them a little acceleration which
means that there needs to be like a
discrete size of protons that can go
through the magnet and be pushed at the
right time a smooth continuous stream of
them would not work and the other thing
is all the protons are positively
charged so they are repelling each each
other the whole time they want to spread
out so we need other magnets to focus
them really really tightly and this is a
enormous technological achievement that
we can do that at something like the
LHC Aaron Bowen says listening to your
physics and crisis solo Edition you
mentioned the use of cutoffs and
effective field Theory to avoid
considering ultraviolet energy levels in
the equations can the same trick be
applied to black holes and the Big Bang
to avoid the singularity and relativity
or am I asking a mathematic naive
question it's not a naive question but
the answer here is no sorry about that
um at least as far as anyone knows the
kinds of Infinities that are coming up
in relativity at the singularity are a
different kind right they're a physical
quantity namely the curvature of
SpaceTime going to Infinity at a
physical place in SpaceTime The
Singularity that's a different thing
than what you have in Quantum field
Theory where you kind of get a fake
Infinity from virtual particles and
virtual particles aren't real particles
that's why they're called virtual
particles they are a way of doing a
mathematical calculation and the fact
that they give you infinity is just an
indication that they're a bad way in
some cases and the ultraviolet cut off
is a way of admitting that these virtual
particles with arbitrarily High energies
weren't really necessary in the first
place whereas as far as we know inside
the black hole that Singularity is
necessary at least as far as classical
general relativity is concerned Samir
says could you please explain how it is
possible to prepare a cubit in a
specific State and then subsequently put
it through a Quantum gate resulting in
the Cubit now being in a super position
BG a hadamard gate hadamard gate is uh
one of the various logic gates that we
use in Quantum Computing so I'm not sure
what what you're hoping is or what
you're thinking is the difficulty here
the original preparation or the later
evolution to prepare a cubit by the way
I should back up actually a cubit is not
a thing right there are various kinds of
things that could represent cubits a
cubit is a two-state Quantum system such
as the spin of an electron or something
like that but there are other things
that could be a cubit so let's just call
it a cubit realizing there's different
physical manifestations of these things
so to if it's an electron with a spin
for example you just measure the spin
and you get either up or down and
therefore as soon as you measure it now
you know exactly what it's in before you
measured it it might have been in some
super position now you know so that part
is relatively easy to put it in a
specific State via a Quantum gate you
just rotate it or something like that
right you put the electron in a magnetic
field and you rotate it a little bit so
if you are measuring spins or discussing
spins relative to the z-axis if you
rotate it from being exactly spin up
along the z-axis to being halfway in
between Spin up and spin down then it's
spin plus X right it's a perpendicular
angle and that corresponds to a superp
position of spin up and spin down so you
don't have to entangle it to actually
manipulate it that's part of the joy of
things entanglement happens in a
specific kind of interaction one that
would interact differently with the two
different states that are in superp
position but just rotating the Cubit or
something like that in the magnetic
field doesn't count as entanglement
that's something you can just do to it
so you can even do that if you don't
know what the original state is right I
can rotate the angle of its axis by
90° without knowing what that original
axis is that's an important thing for
logic gate important property for it to
have Brendan Hall says I'm having a very
College student moment and I've been
moving towards socialist ideas and
Marxist critiques of society and I've
realized that though you had a great
discussion on your moral and political
opinions about animals and IDW things I
don't believe I've heard your comments
on socialist subjects do you accept
these these sorts of criticisms of
capitalism and perhaps accept any of the
more radical opinions of socialist
Traditions I have some sympathies but
I'm not 100% um one thing is I just
haven't sat down and decided on uh an
entire critique of society or favorite
political system or anything like that
so I'm not trying to advertise the
solutions to these Grand problems I tend
to think both that capitalism is very
very good for some things uh it
absolutely helps set prices in
equilibrium it helps stimulate
Innovations a whole bunch of other
things and that it's very very bad at
other things it absolutely allows for it
encourages inequality and concentration
of power and abuse of work workers and a
whole bunch of other things I don't
think it's impossible to have both of
those views at the same time I think
many people do so you don't need to be
extremist Pro capitalism or anti-
capitalism uh but as far as socialism is
concerned so I would very much like much
more of the fraction of our wealth to be
spent making the lives of poor people
better one way or the other I'm a big
believer in just giving them money
whether it's through basic income or
something like that but I don't know if
that where that counts as socialism I
don't know what exact definition you're
going to need to have I don't think it's
in general a good idea uh for the means
of production to be owned by the state
or collectively owned I don't think it's
a good idea to over plan the economy so
many traditional aspects of marxist or
socialist systems uh I'm not a big fan
of so you know I'm kind of a wishy-washy
welfare state capitalist basically um I
think that capitalism is a good starting
point and then you have to very
dramatically modify it to make sure that
its worse instincts don't take over
which they will do unless you stop them
somehow rainbow Bessinger says you
mentioned several times that you were
not a big believer in Heroes your view
makes sense to me as I've been
disappointed in some of my heroes over
time did you always have this view or
was it shaped by disappointing
experiences I don't know if there were
specific disappointing experiences I've
just been around long time and you know
I want to be clear about what the
attitude here is I don't strictly mind
having Heroes um I just think that I
would prefer to admire things that
people do if I don't know them I can
absolutely be um in an admiring stance
towards some accomplishment that someone
has without necessarily therefore
thinking they are a good person because
if I don't know them personally then
what I'm admiring is the little bit I
know about them not their entirety their
Gestalt as a person and it just seems
silly to me when people act surprised
that you know oh this person was a great
scientist but they turned out to be a
terrible jerk in real life yeah that
happens all the time there are great
scientists who are terrible jerks there
are great scientists who are wonderful
people there are people who would make
terrible scientists who are nevertheless
really good people or really bad people
I don't imagine why there should be any
correlation here or anything like that
and that extends more generally in the
sense that just because someone is smart
at something or admirable at something
doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to be smart or admirable at a very
different kind of thing so I would much
rather just be clear about what it is
about a certain person's accomplishments
or abilities that I'm admiring when it
comes to people that you know
personally people who you feel you know
well enough that you have a rounded view
of who they are then I'm very much in
favor of admiring people um but that's
generally not going to be the case for
public figures Tim Converse says
especially in the context of talks about
academic freedom and tenure I'm curious
what you can say from your own
experience about pressures to be more
narrow and to what extend 10e exempts
one from them for example if you had had
10e at Caltech would it have been easier
to say hey so my students are turning in
more philosoph my interests are turning
in more philosophical Direction so
that's what I'm going to do now yay for
tenure and are there context where
breath counts against you all other
things being equal like what about a
physics tenure case with four great
physics journal articles versus that
same case with those same four articles
plus two philosophy articles you know
this is a complicated thing this one of
those things where I to be wishy-washy
but every case is different but overall
the tendency is that yes I think the
tenure does precisely protect professors
in those situations so tenure also
protects professors when they just want
to be lazy right when they stop wanting
to do research or whatever that's the
cost of doing business here but the
important thing is it protects them for
much more admirable reasons when they
want to change their research interests
or be more experimental or more daring
or whatever now the whole system works
very strongly to prevent such people
from getting tenure in the first place
uh I mean of course again it always got
to say if you're a genius you're fine
Geniuses are often able and uh permitted
to bounce around and do a whole bunch of
things but for the rest of us for most
of us the standards are very high and
and departments live in fear of hiring
someone and then they do something else
or do something different or stop doing
things at all so they as I said uh on my
blog years ago they hire on Hope and
they fire on fear they fire on the fear
that you're not going to continue to do
what they they want you to do so it's
absolutely true that at Caltech I could
have more dramatically changed my
research interests for example um I
could probably have changed them anyway
it's it's not perfectly clear you know
at the end of the day I chose to leave
Caltech not only because my research
interests were no longer a fit to what I
had been hired to do but just because
Caltech is not as good a fit to what I
wanted to do and so I just made a
decision that we better to start a new
at a job that really encouraged me to do
exactly what I wanted to do and that
would be happier for everyone as far as
bread counting against you I think it
can absolutely um again because of that
fear aspect you know when you're giving
someone tenure you're making a
prediction about what they will do for
the next 30 Years and whether they what
they will want to do will match up to
what you as the department want them to
do and if what the person has been doing
is
broader than maybe from the point of
view of abstract intellectual
achievement that sounds good but from
the point of view of
predictability it's bad right if they
indicate that there's many different
things that they might want to do that's
a danger sign that's a warning sign that
you're not going to be able to predict
exactly what they want to do so for
departments that are just risk averse
and want to be safe and who they give
tenure to they're going to be much
happier with someone who is not broad
interest much more predictable much more
narrow and down the middle of the
road Mii toor says recently I learned
that the Milky Way takes about 200
million years to perform one full
Revolution it's also estimated to be
13.6 billion years old dividing these
numbers I get 68 full resolution
revolutions so far I find this number
surprisingly small to obtain the
seemingly complex and symmetric
structure that it currently has do you
have any insights into into this I guess
my only Insight is I'm not sure why you
relate the number of revolutions that
the Milky Way has made to its complex
and symmetric structure um you know the
spiral arms that you see in a galaxy
like the Milky Way do not rigidly rotate
with it they are more like this is
complicated but they're more like
regions where star formation is going on
and therefore the Galaxy is brighter
rather than regions where there's more
density or anything like that so if
you're worrying how the spiral structure
forms you know it can form pretty easily
in one or two revolutions I don't I
don't see why it would take even 68 much
less any more than that so I just think
you shouldn't be surprised there 68 the
number of revolutions is more or less
uncoupled to the internal dynamics of
the Galaxy and the galaxy has been going
on for 13.6 billion years so plenty of
time to get pretty darn
intricate Robert RX and rescue says we
know that black holes are maximum
entropy in a region of space time we
also know that the second law states
entropy overwhelmingly tends to go up
but has a very small chance of going
down how would this accidental rare
going down in entropy look like for a
black hole this would mean the black
hole could just by accident and without
emitting any Hawking radiation end up
being smaller just by chance well no it
can't end up being smaller without
emitting any Hawking radiation the
energy is still conserved here so if
it's going to get smaller it has to emit
Hawking radiation but remember when the
black hole does emit Hawking radiation
it gets smaller so the black hole
entropy is less it's just compensated
for by the entropy of the radiation so a
very simple way for the black hole to
fluctuate downward in entropy is to emit
lower entropy radiation and that's
actually pretty easy to imagine how that
could happen very roughly speaking the
entropy of radiation is just the number
of photons that are emitted and black
holes emit usually for a large black
hole very very very low energy photons
but a lot of them and you can calculate
how much entropy there is in the photons
once they're all emitted it's the same
order of magnitude as the original black
hole but it's a bit larger it's a bit
more number of photons so if the black
hole
emitted a bunch of anomalously high
energy
photons thereby giving away more of its
mass in a smaller number of particles
that would represent a spontaneous jump
downward in total
entropy Andrew juwel says I have a
question about dark energy in the
long-term expansion of the universe I've
heard some people say that the galaxies
will hold together just keep getting
farther apart until each Galaxy is alone
in its observable universe but Neil
degrass Tyson asserts that dark Dark
Energy will affect ever de decreasing
scales pulling apart galaxies and then
planets and then atoms which of these
characterizations is correct well it
depends on what the dark energy is
remember I said that it probably is just
vacuum energy the cosmos constant if
that's true then the former scenario is
right uh galaxies will hold together but
get further apart from each other in
fact more specifically gravitationally
bound systems will hold together so if
you have a cluster of galaxies that is
gravitationally bound that will hold
together as nonbound systems move apart
from each other that's not the end of
the story in a galaxy or a cluster uh
the Dynamics are not completely static
so the Stars will bump into each other
they will fall into black holes those
black holes will radiate eventually you
get nothing nothing at all in a little
observable patch of universe if on the
other hand there's this weird and
extremely unlikely phenomenon called
Phantom energy in that case the energy
density per cubic centimeter does not
remain constant but actually goes up and
in that case which was worked out by
Robert calwell Mark kimy and kowsky and
others then individual galaxies would be
ripped apart then there's an increasing
push apart um on individual objects in
the universe all the way down to atoms
but like I said that scenario is
extremely unlikely I wrote a paper uh
with Mark trodden and Mark Hoffman where
we explained that for that to work you
would basically need a field Theory with
negative energy particles and negative
energy particles are just bad to have in
your field Theory so my bet is that the
dark energy is just constant and
galaxies are going to be fine until they
collapse in on
themselves Jim Murphy says I've been
having having an argument with a friend
of mine he believes that the general
population is on the whole un interested
in philosophy and science while I
disagree he claims that my perspective
is biased by the people who I surround
myself with namely curious people who
enjoy investigating challenging
questions about reality do you believe
that the average person is drawn to
scientific inquiry and deep questions or
are most people blissfully ignorant well
look let's let's be fair to the average
person it's completely okay to not be
drawn to scientific inquiry and deep
questions and still not be blissfully
ignorant okay there's a big gap in
between those two
characterizations life is short we have
to pick and choose what we're interested
in very few people are interested in
scientific uh deep scientific questions
and deep literary questions and deep
musical questions and speaking lots of
foreign languages and knowing how to
build refrigerators and a whole bunch of
other things right most things we don't
get the chance to be experts on and even
I think it's called completely okay to
not want to be an expert on too many
things there's different ways you can
craft a worthwhile and rewarding life
having said that um probably you know
look I don't know I don't know because
the question is a little bit too vague
what what is it mean to say the general
population is uninterested in philosophy
and science maybe maybe most people are
a little bit interested but not too
interested I I would rather say that I
am happily surprised all the time by the
large number people who are sincerely
interested in it I don't know what that
number is compared to the majority but
there's a lot of them you know I went to
give a talk in Copenhagen science and
Cocktails I give a talk on quantum
mechanics and it's a Friday night
there's a thousand people in the
audience just to hear a talk on quantum
mechanics on a Friday night and that
that just makes me very happy the number
of people who listen to mindscape makes
me very happy so I'm not worried about
the average person I just want every
person to be able to understand as much
science as they are interested
in Michael Lacy says have you made any
endof life plans in particular have you
decided on a standard burial cremation
green burial or donating your body to a
body Farm or other research
facility yeah I think that uh no nothing
explicit I don't have a funeral home
lined up or anything like that but uh
cremation is my preferred thing to do
and people know it so I think that's
what's going to happen um I don't I
don't feel strongly that that's the
right thing to do and other people
should do it but for me I think that's
about what I want Andre chavanet says is
acceleration really an absolute quantity
I've thought that in the framework of
general relativity acceleration is
relative that there is no experiment to
find out whether one is accelerating or
not so nope that is that's not right I
just wanted to is a quick answer but
position is relative in relativity
there's no preferred position position
velocity is relative there's no
preferred velocity but acceleration is
absolutely measurable uh you can know
whether you're accelerating are you
being pushed back in your chair or
whatever you're in uh there's absolutely
a set of trajectories that are preferred
which are the unaccelerated or inertial
trajectories in general
relativity Jeffrey seagull says you
mentioned about writing ideas in a
fictional narrative I was wondering if
you ever saw the movie My Dinner with
Andre and what you thought about it I
liked this it was quite a while ago well
my wife hated it I did see it but it was
also quite a while ago for me so I am
therefore not exactly sure why you are
relating this to the idea of writing
ideas in a fictional narrative um you
know in some sense okay my Dinner with
Andre as I vaguely remember Wallace
Shawn and Andre Gregory are sitting
there talking throughout the whole movie
an hour and a half or whatever it is
about slightly different approaches to
life right with Wallace Shan being the
slightly more downto earth guy Andre
Gregory being a bit more spiritual and
new AG although don't remember whether
that term existed at the time I really
like the movie um I love the movie it
was fun it's certainly uh kind of I
don't want to say radical movie but you
know it it was very explicitly very
knowingly different right they literally
made a movie of two people sitting down
and talking and it was
not the them playing themselves okay
even though it was close Wallace Shan's
character's name was Wally Andre
Gregory's character's name was Andre but
it wasn't like they were just shooting
the breeze it was a tightly constructed
script ahead of time they had a point
for where they were going and so forth
for the right people it's a great movie
um if I did ever myself write about in a
fictional vein uh it wouldn't be quite
that explicitly d actic I would try to
have a couple more action scenes than
that
one nichel Kramer says I'd like to ask
your advice about talking to non-physics
e friends a not uncommon question is
about wave particle duality a on line
answer I found myself using is that a
reasonable way to think about it is that
light and other objects travel about
like a wave but they interact with each
other with other objects like a particle
does this seem like a reasonable way to
go about this I think it's reasonable
you know it's okay but I I pref prer a
slightly different way of saying it
which is that if you're not looking at
it this stuff behaves like a wave um
whereas if you measure it if You observe
it if you try to figure out the value of
an observable quantity what you see
looks more particle likee even that is
not exactly true there's subtleties
there but I think it's a slightly more
sharp distinction than interacting with
other objects because after all a
particle moving in a gravitational field
is interacting with the thing that is
causing the gravitational field but it
doesn't cause that thing to act particle
like cuz that doesn't count as a
measurement it's not decohering it's not
becoming entangled with
anything Sandro Stuy says in your
Reflections on the episode with rosemary
Brown you considered two possible
explanations for why your guests often
end up having a background in physics
that you were not aware of when you
invited them one physics training is
great and applicable in many domains and
two it's easier to come up with
questions and make progress in other
areas so physicists move there but what
about unconscious familiarity bias could
it not be that some of your prospective
guests have that certain junqua that
subconsciously makes you more likely to
invite them as usual I'm going to
confess I don't have any idea what I
said in the the reflection video the
idea the reflection videos is you know
even less planned than usual I just
literally sit down after the podcast and
record them right away um so I'm but I'm
surprised I said that because I think
your explanation is absolutely the right
one and the one that I would give the
most Credence to it's not that I
randomly select people who are doing
interesting things I select people who
are doing interesting things to me that
is to say that's that was the wrong way
to say it they're not doing things to me
they're doing things that are
interesting to me and it's therefore
very unsurprising that they would be
physics oriented in one way or another
even if they end up in economics or
biology or whatever Ahad chaker says I
heard in an accelerator like the large
hron collider that we can't detect
neutrinos so we infer them from leftover
energy from collisions but how do we
know it's a just a neutrino and not some
other neutral particle in addition to
that well basically because we know how
many neutrinos there are and we also
know exactly how they interact with the
known particles so whenever you do one
of these experiments you predict how
much energy should be lost in neutrinos
coming out on
average and then you try to fit to the
data and if you do fit to the data then
what you say is well that's consistent
with a certain number of neutrinos and
by the way this is why you will often
see the you know the measured number of
neutrinos in this experiment is
3.1 uh the measured sorry what that
means is not the actual number of
nutrino particles that came out but the
number of nutrino flavors that are
implied by the experiment in the real
world we have three nutrino flavors that
we know about the electron nutrino the
muon nutrino the to nutrino so the
reason why you say something like 3.1 is
because you measured a total amount of
energy that is missing and then you fit
it to the prediction from knowing that
there are three different flavors of
neutrinos so and 3.1 is very reasonable
because it's 3.1 plus or minus point2
right and famously the experiment did
that did that the best is actually not
the LHC but its predecessor LEP the
large electron positron collider because
electron positron colliders you can
measure the total energy in the initial
uh event much more precisely in the LHC
we say we're colliding protons but
really inside the protons are all these
quarks and gluons and those are what
knock into each other so even though you
know the energy of the proton quite well
you don't actually know the precise
energy of the part of the proton that
did the colliding so in a Large Hadron
Collider you're not going to have
exactly the same Precision for the total
energy to start with that you do at a
lepton collider an electron positron
collider so the best limits on the
number of nutrino come from LEP rather
than the
LHC Frederick Apollo says I hear you say
that the electron is point-like but also
that it has an extent given by the
Compton wavelength how do we reconcile
those two so I don't think I ever say or
at least I try not to say that the
electron is point like other people do
but I will say the electron is a field
right not a particle it it looks
particle like and the particle itself
that it looks like has zero extent when
you measure the particle but the Compton
wavelength has more to do with how well
you can localize a single electron and
still keep it looking particle like
because in Quantum field theory of
course if you put pump enough energy
into the electron field you can make
more electrons as long as you make an
equal number of positrons right so what
happens is if if you squeeze an electron
to smaller and smaller distances uh its
energy goes up because energy is
inversely proportional to wavelength in
quantum theory so the Compton wavelength
is the smallest wavelength that you can
have for the electron's wave function
such that you can reliably say it is
just one electron rather than some
superposition of one and three and and
whatever
if you want more on that I can recommend
that you buy my upcoming book you can
race out right now and pre-order Quant
and Fields and that will explain these
things in a little bit more
detail Dave grund
good Dave grunder says in your September
AMA you said that Humanity has the power
to house everyone but we're choosing not
to I agree 100% but I don't think I know
how to turn that into personal action
that I can take do you have any ideas
about how individual humans can leverage
their individual Power of Choice to
nudge Collective Humanity toward Utopia
well I think that when you put it that
way you know you're kind of answering
your own question an individual a single
person for most of us for most of us
individuals has very very very little
power to nudge the billions of people
constituting the human race toward
Utopia and even more than that that
doesn't mean you have zero power but it
just means that you only have a little
so don't be surprised if you don't
personally lead to widescale changes in
human behavior but you do have a little
for instance you could vote in elections
you can convince other people to vote
for the right candidates you can donate
to political parties uh you can try to
learn more about the issues and put your
money and energy into the wisest
possible schemes and I I say this very
explicitly even though it's kind of like
self-evident and Dopey because I do
think that there's
this kind of bloess or cynicism that
that settles in that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy when people
start saying oh well you know politics
is never going to fix anything
politicians are all crooked the parties
are the same as each other there's no
point in doing it you are the problem
that is why politics is not very good
because people don't make the effort I
think that politics matters I think that
politics is crucially important I don't
like it when people say we shouldn't
talk about politics or politics is a
distraction or politics makes you dumber
or whatever politics is absolutely
Central and important and as messy and
dislikable as it may be it's the way to
have large scale change for the behavior
of all human beings so whether it's just
a little bit you know voting or wearing
a t-shirt or whatever or whether it's
diving head forth into creating
political change that's the way to make
a big change in how human beings
behave Rue Phillips says is gravity
really not a force and are physicists in
denial about it in a tweet from David
Deutsch on 928 he said the following
about gravity no force is exerted by
gravity if if you hold out your arm the
only force on it is from your own
muscles very few people know this I've
known physicist to deny it sainaa
hossenfelder confirmed this tweet by
replying he is correct of course both in
saying that gravity is not a force and
that a significant fraction of
physicists deny it
look it's a definitional question you're
arguing about the definition of the word
Force I can invent definitions under
which gravity is a force I can invent
definitions in which it's
not there it is interesting that gravity
is a feature of SpaceTime in a way that
the other forces are not that's
interesting that's at the heart of the
equivalence principle and what motivated
Einstein to invention relativity and so
forth and therefore you are allowed to
distinguish Gravity from the other
forces of nature it's Universal right it
affects other things the same whether no
matter what they're made of no matter
how heavy they are and so forth It's not
like electromagnetism that affects you
very differently if you're positively
charged or negatively charged and
therefore it is perfectly legitimate to
say unlike electromagnetism or the
strong force or whatever gravity isn't a
force gravity is a feature of SpaceTime
namely the curvature of
SpaceTime it's also completely 100%
legitimate to say there are four forces
of nature gravity strong weak and
electromagnetic forces you know what is
meant by that and you're conveying
correct information it would be much
more relevant to say do physicists know
general
relativity that's a non-trivial question
and the answer might be yes or no and it
doesn't really come down to definitions
most physicists you know most people who
get phds in physics never take a course
in general relativity they know the
popular level understanding of it but
they don't know tensor calculus or
differential geometry or anything like
that is that bad I don't know most
businesses don't use general relativity
I think it's much more common now than
when I was in graduate school but it's
probably still not a majority most
physicists don't need general relativity
and but nevertheless it is interesting
um because on the outside world you
probably think that general relativity
is absolutely Central to a physicist
education but for most it it's just
not George says I was briefly introduced
to igen States today in my chemistry
lecture but we were told that specific
particles cannot exist at energies
between ion States could you please
elaborate on the exact reason why they
cannot exist between these igon states
well I think your problem George is that
you were at a chemistry lecture ra
rather than a physics lecture it's not I
mean I get what was being said and it's
not it is in the vicinity of something
true but it's a little bit misleading
you know electrons are quantum particles
right or they excitations in Quantum
Fields you have to use the quantum
language to describe what is going on so
there's two things that are going on
here one is that indeed in atoms there
are energy igen states that correspond
to the different orbitals that electrons
can be in and the general Quantum state
of an electron will be even even if we
know that it's in a particular atom it's
going to be in a superposition of all of
those different energy igen states okay
so there's no rule it has to be in one
specific igon State rather than another
strictly speaking however in the real
world if you have an atom and you put an
electron in a state that is not an
energy ion State it's going to Decay
it's going to give off a photon to go
down to a lower energy and in fact it's
going to go down to the lowest energy it
can that might not be the absolutely
lowest energy of all the possible igen
States because maybe there's another
electron already there so given that
there are already electrons there up to
that one constraint and the the
exclusion principle that says no two
electrons can be in exactly the same
state the electron will go to the lowest
possible igen state it can therefore
after you let the electrons settle down
it is an empirical fact that all the
electrons will individually be in energy
igen
states Lewis B says are there good
theoretical reasons why we think that a
dark matter candidate wimp should weakly
interact as opposed to being a
non-interacting massive particle
completely non-interacting I guess or is
this just a case of being hopeful it
interacts because otherwise finding it
would be impossible no it actually does
matter that it's weak interactions this
is called the wimp Miracle because you
can't just say I have a particle that is
dark that would make a good Dark Matter
candidate you have to explain why it has
the abundance that it does in the
universe why there is a certain number
of Dark Matter particles that gives you
the right energy density compared to
photons for example
and what generally happens is at the
very very early Universe when the
temperatures are extremely high if the
temperature is higher than the mass of
your particle when E equals mc^ s so
we're measuring mass and energy and
temperature all in the same units then
you're going to be creating and
annihilating your particle over and over
again in the thermal plasma whereas when
the energy goes below the mass of the
particle so the temperature goes below
the mass then the particles stop
interacting and then more or less they
do what is called freezing out they
basically have a fixed Relic abundance
so if you think about it if you know the
mass of the particle and you know its
interaction strength then you can go
backwards and say okay when did it
freeze out and how much particle should
be left in the current Universe this is
called a freeze out calculation and you
get the right answer if the particles
you're thinking about have approximately
weak scale interaction strengths and
masses so that's nice I mean there's no
reason why the right Relic abundance of
Dark Matter should have anything to do
with the weak interaction of particle
physics but they do apparently you know
if we
were strongly interacting if if you got
the uh if the right Relic abundance
corresponded with strong interactions
you might be in trouble it might be
harder to fit the astrophysical data
that way um and if the if the Relic
abundance that you wanted came out of a
a interaction cross-section that was
much lower than the weak interactions
then you would have to invent a whole
new Force right which we you could do of
course but it's been very very
suggestive that the right abundance
comes out of putting in the weak
interactions doesn't mean it's right but
that's a a hint hopefully that we can go
help to use to go look for the particles
which is what we're
doing OA or owwe says says I'm working
through the older podcast and just went
through the conversation with Mike Brown
AKA Pluto killer I got really curious
and started reading up on the
hypothetical Planet 9 one of the
proposed theories is that it's not a
planet but rather a primordial black
hole putting aside the probability my
initial thought was of concern as black
holes can be pretty destructive objects
how dangerous would it be for there to
be a planetary Mass black hole within
500 astronomical units of the solar
system you know roughly speaking not
dangerous at all
uh for one thing if it's in orbit Planet
N9 has an orbit and that orbit is very
far away so there's no reason for it to
go out of the orbit unless some
nefarious aliens want to you know move
it and point it at the Earth for another
thing it a black hole the mass of the
earth is a very tiny thing actually it's
certainly no more dangerous than a
planet the mass of the Earth if a planet
ran into the Earth that would be bad if
a black hole ran into the Earth that
would also be bad but one wouldn't
necessarily be worse than the other
maybe even in some sense the planet is
more dangerous because since it's bigger
the chances that it hits the Earth are
are bigger but overall an object whether
it's a planet or a black hole that is
the mass of the Earth that's just not a
lot of mass solar system speaking so I
would be much more worried about comets
and and asteroids uh that might impact
the Earth because just there's a lot
more of them even though they're much
tinier Davis Yoshida says David Albert
and Barry lower both expressed
skepticism about the idea of
self-locating
probabilities they both said something
along the lines of needing to see more
details about how these probabilities
behave now that it's been a few years do
you feel their concerns have been
answered if so where can I read more
about the topic well I don't know if
this is useful or not but I thought
their concerns were already answered I
don't think there's any new thing that
has happened in the past few years that
clears anything up but I think that even
when I was talking to each of them um my
answers were perfectly satisfying to me
depends on what you mean by behaving
like how they behave um they they behave
exactly like probabilities that these
self-locating uncertainties are attached
credences if you have an exclusive set
of possibilities the credences for all
those possibilities will add up to one
there will be numbers between zero and
one that add up to one are conserved
over time everything you want a
probability to be in fact in the paper
that chip seens and I um wrote to derive
the born rule in many worlds the way
that I like to think about it you know
we went through various hoops and and
math and so forth but the moral of the
story is the born rule the assignment of
the probability being the wave function
squared is really just the perfectly
obvious natural thing to do in quantum
mechanics once you believe they are
probabilities at all those probabilities
have to have certain properties and
those properties more or less uniquely
point you toward the born rule so the
reason why David and Barry want to avoid
that uh well I shouldn't I'm not trying
to psychoanalyze them but they have to
to be consistent deny the idea of
self-locating probabilities uh as a
coherent thing because once you let that
in once you say okay you know you have
some uncertainty about which branch of
the wave function you're on we have to
assign some credences to them what can
we do the answer is instantly the Bor
rule in many worlds works and you
believe it and that's a good position to
be in but if you're not going to believe
many worlds then then I think that
denying the sensibility of having
self-locating credences is a sens
sensible thing to do I just don't feel
the urge to do that ktie spaghetti says
what are your thoughts on the philosophy
and foundations of mathematics and the
real numbers numbers I.E the Continuum
do real numbers infinite non-re
repeating decimals exist in the real
world you know I don't know whether they
do or not I don't mind if they do I
think that it's undoubtedly the
case
that once a mathematical system becomes
sufficiently powerful it opens itself up
to unfortunate properties right like
girdles incompleteness theorem or
various theorems about decidability and
and predictability and and things like
that um various mismatches between sets
of axioms and models of those axioms the
piano axioms p n o are famously axioms
that uh underly arithmetic and the
natural numbers but not uniquely they
don't give you uniquely the integers
that you know and love there's other
models of the piano um arithmetic axioms
and there's no way to just add an extra
Axiom that picks out the right one so
this leads people to mathematical
platonism and believing that we just
know what the right model of piano
axioms is and I that none of that is at
all um convincing to me so therefore it
would be nice if we didn't have to use a
mathematical systems that were quite
that powerful I did recently write a
paper on discret completely discret
quantum mechanics
that pointed out that it is conceivable
not easy and not even very nice honestly
but conceivable that you could have a
phenomenologically acceptable theory of
quantum mechanics without the Continuum
with only discrete numbers uh maybe the
big problem there is actually um Believe
It or Not ironically boltzman brains if
you have a completely discrete quantum
mechanics you will generally have
recurrences and maybe not necessarily
neily but generally you will
um I'm trying to think if you have a
completely discret quantum mechanics in
a finite dimensional Hilbert space then
you will generally have recurrences and
those those include fluctuations and
those include boltzman brains which are
bad okay so that's the
big phenomenological problem that you
have to get out of somehow uh the
cosmological issues but otherwise as far
as you know the current universe is
concerned we can fit the data with
completely discret quantum mechanics
which is to think about I don't know
whether that helps with the philosophy
of mathematics and the various
conundrums that arise there but it's a
it's an open
possibility Brandon Lewis says how do
you feel about the new wave of fusion
power startups do any of them seem
promising so I have no idea uh I I don't
want to answer the question in the sense
of trying to provide an opinion about
these things I have no idea about but I
thought I wanted to answer the question
or address it because I want to put in a
little word in favor of fusion power you
know nuclear fusion has been hyped for
decades now and the hype is often gotten
out of control and it's often turned out
to be false right so I think that a
certain weariness and cynicism sets in
where people go oh yeah okay another
round of fusion hype but look David Hume
would tell you this kind of induction
doesn't work uh it is completely
possible that a 100 years from now we
will say oh yeah there's like 50 years
of complete hype before we finally
figured out how to do it and it changed
the world right that is an open
possibility I think it's okay to lower
your Credence in the usefulness of
fusion based on the fact that many
people have tried and failed but it
shouldn't be zero so I'm very open to
the idea in general that the technology
has improved to such a place where soon
we will have fusion power I am not an
expert don't don't take that as the op
opinion of a physicist who has sat down
and looked at the issues because I have
not but I just want to be open-minded to
the idea that Fields can be overhyped
and nevertheless eventually pay
off Ryan vaugh says if the arrow of time
arises from increasing entropy why do we
perceive time to advance at a constant
rate 1 second per second when entropy
increases at varying rates say inside a
star versus Interstellar space well to
be super duper clear I often say this
but I'll say try to say it in slightly
different words the arrow of time is
just a direction it is not a magnitude
it is not a statement that there is
something called the rate at which time
goes entropy has nothing to do with
one's perception of the rate at which
time passes or anything like that as you
say time passes at 1 second per second
the rate at which entropy is increasing
has nothing to do with our perception of
the passage of time what it it has to do
with is we always perceive time to pass
from the past to the Future that's all
that it says it is just a difference
between past and future not a
quantitative rate of anything at
all Russ Dill says in your paper with
bow and sing on the hbur space of
quantum gravity you discuss the limited
degrees of freedom of a local region of
space and how it limits black holes does
this also limit the compactness of the
early Universe additionally with the
special low entropy state of the early
Universe allow it to be more compact
than if it were in some other state well
no not really so the way to think about
this we actually talked about in a
different paper called uh Quantum
circuit
cosmology uh also with ning BAU Charles
saao and Liam McAllister and what we
point out is if You' buy the basic idea
that space emerges from a bunch of
entangled cubits and you want to explain
how space expands then what you do is
you have a big bunch of cubits only some
of them are entangled the others are
just not entangled and not participating
in space itself okay so they exist in
some sense but they don't actually
contribute to what you and I think of as
space so the nice thing about this way
of thinking is you can understand in a
Quantum level what it means to say the
universe is expanding what it means to
say that is these initially unentangled
cubits are gradually
entangling with the rest of the universe
and making space bigger okay so we wrote
a little paper you know pointing out
that that is more or less uh a sensible
story we don't have the full story it's
very very far from a complete well
fleshed out Theory but there's no sort
of logical um reason why it wouldn't
work and in fact in my mind it helps
explains something that is otherwise
very mysterious you know when in the
usual semi-classical way of talking
about the expansion of space you have
space expanding and you have Quantum
Fields within that space and these
Quantum Fields it is easiest to think
about them in terms of waves whose
wavelengths also expand along with the
universe which is fine and good and if
you do you know inflationary cosmology
or cosmological peration Theory you need
to think in those terms but it has the
obvious problem that if you go backward
in time something like you know the the
typical Cosmic micro background Photon
right now at what most cosmologists
think of at as the beginning of the
universe or you know the beginning of
inflation was much smaller than the
plank scale that's a problem you're not
supposed to have things much smaller
than the plank scale what were those
modes doing when they were smaller than
the pling scale so our picture answers
that question what were those modes
doing namely they were not entangled
they were not part of what you call
space at all it's not that they were TR
plunking and somehow bubbled down to our
world they were always there but they
just weren't participating in the
broader entangled group of cubits that
were making up space as we know
it okay Pete fauler says in the context
of the cosmological Multiverse I often
hear people say things like if we wait
long enough or somewhere very far away
when discussing phenomena such as
boltzman brains or exact doppelgangers
if these phenomena are predicted due to
purely random fluctuations then surely
the likelihood of them happening in the
distant future or very far away are the
same as them happening in the next 5
minutes or close by they're both
incredibly small yes that is exactly
true so when we say if we wait long
enough we'll see a boltzman brain we
mean exactly the same thing as if you
flip a coin enough times eventually you
will see it come up heads 100 times in a
row it's not that the rate or the
likelihood is changing from moment to
moment it's just that you have to wait a
very very long time for the total
probability to approach anything
appreciable the memes of Destruction
says how would you recommend a lay
person conceptualize how time can become
space and vice versa I would not
recommend the lay person conceptualized
that at all uh I don't even know exactly
what it means for time to become space
and in relativity obviously there's only
one thing namely SpaceTime and there is
a Tim like Direction and space likee
directions and those are not completely
uniquely fixed because it's relativity
and different observers will divide
SpaceTime into time and space
differently but that's no different than
saying you know two people might lay
down a grid to make a city differently
right I mean it's just a choice
coordinates it's not that one is
becoming the other as anything dynamical
so I don't know if that helps but that's
the best thing I can do for that
question Sid Huff asks a priority
question imagine two spaceships flying
in parallel some distance apart say 10
kilomet there is a super strong long
wire stretched between them the ships
fly on either side of a smallish black
hole in space such that the wire cuts
through the black hole what would happen
to the wire and to the black
hole I think you can work this out for
yourself honestly um just be serious
about what you're asking if if part of
the wire falls into the black hole that
part is never coming out that's all
there is all she wrote so the part that
is just outside the black hole has two
choices either it will be pulled into
the black hole in which case you know
the wires and the spaceships and
everything just fall into the black hole
or it breaks those are the only two
options I don't know exactly which
option it will be that depends on the
wire but one of those two things will
happen Cubit says in your materialistic
view of the world even morality emerges
from physical laws on the most
fundamental level do you think there's
any chance of finding a moral principle
which attributes Consciousness to some
kind of exotic Advanced Computer which
does not have any humanik properties
certainly we do not feel compassion
towards such a device and therefore
seems hard to imagine why we would
attribute Consciousness to it anyway I
have um no problem whatsoever in
believing that a sufficiently Advanced
Computer can have what you and I
recognize as Consciousness or even human
rights or agency or anything like that
again I I I think that we're making a
huge mistake of principle in how we
typically talk and think about
artificial intelligence in the modern
world we're just borrowing human words
and applying them way too quickly to a
very very different thing
human beings are embodied creatures they
are not designed by anybody uh there's a
whole bunch of things that go along with
being human
therefore it is not at all obvious that
anytime soon we will get anything that
you and I recognize as conscious or
deserving of compassion um even if we do
get things that fake it very very well
and I say all that because I also want
to say
nevertheless I see no obstacle to
eventually doing it um human beings are
just physical things just like computers
are so no if I'm consistent about it I
can't possibly say there is something
about our squishy biology that makes us
deserving of compassion but not
something that would be made of
silicon David Maxwell says watching
Oppenheimer I found myself imagining
what the world might be like had the US
made theoretical physics an
intergenerational priority how much do
you think the pace of advancement in
theoretical physics is limited by the
number of people doing it are there
inherent limitations to the pace of
change beyond the number of brain
hours I don't know you know the pace of
progress in theoretical physics I think
has been fine you know you got to give
nature some credit here okay uh there's
no rule that says we'll learn more about
the universe if we just throw more
brains at it um probably there is some
improvement in the rate of progress but
it's probably sublinear right it's not
like if we have twice as many people
doing theoretical physics we'll make
twice as much progress I love
theoretical physics and I think it's
worthy of more support than it gets from
uh governments and things like that but
there's no way of knowing what the rate
of progress is going to be no matter how
much money we throw at it um maybe the
progress would have been much greater
because one person would have had a
really good idea that we haven't had yet
or maybe not I don't I don't know so I
think that the you know right thing to
do is to well let's back
up if you're really a country or a
nation or a society you have a really
really hard problem in front of you
which is how to allocate your resources
amidst a bunch of things that are worth
doing right theoretical physics is worth
doing so is experimental physics so is
biology so is chemistry so are history
and literature and a whole bunch of
other things not to mention
manufacturing and engineering and
medicine and what have you so nobody
knows enough about the details of all of
these things to really accurately do it
it's a very weird situation where
certain members of those different
subcommunities have to make a case right
they have to try to communicate to the
rest of the world what is going on in
their fields why it is worth supporting
what can be done with the money and
things like that um in my very very tiny
way this is part of the goal of things
like my books and my podcasts just to
let people know why these ideas are so
interesting and important and and then
hopefully they decide that they're worth
supporting that's what I would like but
you know other things are worth
supporting too and I and I totally
believe that I you know I sometimes
wonder whether different academics
aren't a little bit too honest about how
uh what they do is well it's just one of
the things that is worth supporting cuz
I mean that's true but if other areas of
human endeavor are much more like just
give me the money then I worry that
those areas are going to
win okay final question for this AMA
comes from The Great Deceiver who
actually despite the uh handle is going
to ask quite a sweet question a few
years ago I was walking alone at night
hitchhiking in Argentina and I was
treated to the most wonderful night sky
that I've ever experienced and probably
ever will experience I can see clear
across the Galaxy I'm wondering if you
have ever been to South America to take
in any of the amazing telescopes like
The BLT in China or others maybe in
graduate school what would you Delight
in peering at if you had full rain in
one of those facilities uh so let me get
some of the some of the Annoying details
out of the way first sadly the VT the
very large telescope did not exist when
I was in graduate school so I couldn't
look through it um and more importantly
there's no peering through it when it
comes to these big telescopes there's no
eyepiece right there are photographic or
other instruments uh connected to them
most of the time they're taking Spectra
even not images um I think that various
people have learned the pr value of
taking images as well as the scientific
Valu so these days you get more images
because you have large CCD cameras but
it's the Spectra which often reveal more
information to the astronomers than the
pictures do okay having said all that um
I have been to South America several
times and other parts of the Southern
Hemisphere and yeah the the sky is very
beautiful also the sky in the northern
hemisphere is also extremely beautiful
if you're in a dark enough area um I I
this is going to sound weird but as much
as I love the night sky I mean the Milky
Way in particular gets to me I don't
need a power ful telescope because
powerful telescopes would zoom in on
some nebula or star or planet or
whatever I prefer in my all inspiring
night sky experiences to look at the
whole Milky Way all at once you know
knowing that it's a big disc and that
we're near the edge of it to me like how
can you look at that and not get vertigo
get a little dizzy knowing that where
you are in the Milky Way um but having
said that looking at the night sky is
not what gets me going really what gets
me going and this is you know as geeky
as I'm ever going to get what gets me
going is knowing that we can invent
equations or discover equations
depending on your philosophical
preferences that correctly describe
what's going on when we see those
amazing things and and that's me and I
love astronomy in the night sky I was an
astronomy major I had a part-time job
showing people the night sky I was an
undergraduate but uh it's not what
really gets me going it's the
possibility of understanding the
intellectual puzzle that we have been
extraordinarily successful and making
progress on we're not near nearly done
but what we've learned by doing science
and thinking about what is happening out
there in the sky and in the rest of
reality is what really amazes me and uh
keeps me excited to learn more and think
about more and I'm very glad that you
all are here with me on the journey to
learn more about universe so thank you
very much see you next week thanks for
supporting mindscape
[Music]
bye-bye